vous verrez bien venu pour ce nouvel
épisode de probablement aujourd'hui
j'accueille gilles dowek professeur à
l'inra et chercheur à l'inra et
professeur à hoeness paris saclay
bonjour lille bonjour comment ça va ça
va est ce que tu pourrais commencer par
de présenter un petit peu 31
l'entente est ton parcours alors j'ai un
parcours très classique concret très
très ennuyeux j'ai d'abord fait une
école d'ingénieurs qui s'appelle l'école
polytechnique
ensuite en fait avant même de faire
cette école j'avais envie d'être
chercheur j'avais décidé de faire des
études en sciences parce que je voulais
de chercheurs donc assez naturellement
après avoir eu mon diplôme d'ingénieur
j'ai préparé une telle et puis après
matin j'ai un peu voyagé dans le monde
j'ai rendu visite à des collègues dans
un laboratoire à pittsburgh hier pendant
six mois puis ensuite à austin au texas
pendant six autres mois
et puis je suis revenu à paris où j'ai
d'abord cru à un emploi de chercheur à
l'inria donc un institut de recherche
et puis après quelques années j'ai su
retourner à l'école polytechnique pour
enseigner et puis champion des mines rio
puis maintenant je suis à la fois inria
et à l'école normale de paris saclay et
du coup quand tu t'intéresses et a dit
qu'on était en informatique quantité
intéressés informatique alors c'était
c'est une très vieille très histoire
parce que jusqu'à ce que j'ai 14 15 ans
je m'intéressais pas trop à
l'informatique le savez appel que ça que
ça existait puis quand je suis arrivé au
lycée et au lycée descartes un automne
il y avait un club d'informatique donc
j'ai commencé à prendre un peu à
programmer la et puis je m'étais
intéressé à cette époque ya des des
programmes de jeu donc je m'étais
focaliser sur un jeu qui était le
mastermind allongée ce mois ci encore
des gens qui savent jouer au mr nice
mais c'était un jeu qui était très
populaire au 20e siècle est bon j'avais
écrit un programme qui jouait va se
terminer et qui joue et qui voit pas
trop mal
et il y avait à cette époque à une
entreprise qui s'appelait philippe ce
qui est organisé chaque année un
concours pour des jeunes scientifiques
donc c'était des scientifiques amateurs
il y avait moins de 21 ans et j'ai
envoyé un document qui décrit mais ce
que j'avais fait dans mon programme et
comment j'avais utilisé un peu de
théorie de l'information pour des biens
ont relativement bien jouer mastermind
et alors il y avait un jury de ce prix
qui dans lequel et dont faisait partie
jacques louis lions ce qui était à cette
époque le président d'inria et donc lyon
salue ce que j'ai ce que j'avais écrit
l'a fait lire à un autre chercheur qui
s'appelle gérard huet qui était aussi un
chercheur à l'inria cette époque qu'il a
fait lire à un autre chercheur qui
s'appelait françois fages
et puis gérard et françois m'ont invité
à passer 15 jours dans dans leur équipe
et alors que le assez naïvement que
c'était en fait les vacances de noël
quand j'étais en terminale es assez
naïvement moi ce qui m'intéressait
c'était pas du tout les recherches que
gérard et françois abonnés
ce qui m'intéressait c'est qu'ils
avaient un énorme ordinateur c'est un
ordinateur qui avait plusieurs ko de
mémoire et donc moi comme j'avais un
ordinateur qui n'avait qu'un kilo de
mémoire j'étais assez limité dans ce que
j'avais pu implémenter sur bon sur vos
calculatrices programmables donc leur
avis en fait que vous faites m'intéresse
pas du tout ce que je vois c'est accéder
à votre ordinateur donc assez
naturellement face et à une pop
bienveillance en fait ils m'ont dit bloc
fff est ce que tu veux
et puis donc après on est resté en
contact donc ça c'était quand j'avais 16
ans 17 ans puis après donc j'ai fait des
études
et quand j'ai cherché un directeur de
test assez naturellement j'ai réécrit à
gérard et je vais dire voilà je vais
continuer alors non pas sur le master
mind mais cette fois ci je me fais un
peu plus intéressés à ce qu'ils
faisaient dans dans son équipe et c'est
comme ça que j'ai commencé une thèse
d'une thèse avec lui et il y avait
quelque chose qui m'avait vraiment
marquer quand j'avais fait ce stage
c'est que quand même j'étais un tout
petit peu intéressé est ce qu'ils
faisaient et géra m'avait expliqué que
le problème de la rai et est indécidable
c'est à dire qu'il y avait un problème
qu'on ne pouvait absolument pas résoudre
avec à l'ordinateur ou en écrivant à un
programme il n'existait pas
d'algorithmes pour résoudre ce problème
donc au début ça me j'avais mal compris
ce qu'il nous est enfin je pensais qu'il
ne disait mal je faisais tu veux dire
qu'on en a pas encore trouvé en fait non
c'était pas qu'on allait pas encore
trouvé c'était vraiment qu'il est
impossible qu'il en existe un et alors
ça m'a complètement changé la vision
qu'avaient de l'informatique était
j'avais plutôt l'idée que l'informatique
c'était d'écrire des programmes et de
réaliser des trucs et puis je me suis
aperçu qu'il y avait une vraie si on se
voit qu'ils avaient vraiment des
connaissances en informatique des
résultats négatifs en particulier et
donc là c'est ça qui est un peu
déterminé ma vocation à devenir
chercheur en informatique
ok mais comprenez l'heure actuelle a
compris qu'on était en terminale ou non
non j'ai pas content non non pas du tout
j'ai raté pas fous ils n'avaient pas
cherché à m'expliquer pourquoi c'était
un des fidèles
d'abord c'était beaucoup plus mystérieux
qui me disent que c'est elle décida mais
je ne sache pas pourquoi et non après
j'ai compris ça comme tout le monde
quand j'étais à l'université enfin dans
au moment où j'ai roulé après un master
mind esprit vitesse et chacun choisit
des bisounours
ouais c'est ça alors il ya deux joueurs
qui jouent un rôle assez différent il y
en a qui est assez passive qui cache à
un code donc il ya des pions de quatre
couleurs donc il n'y a pas d'envié
quatre pions parmi des pions que six
couleurs et donc ils sont cachés et
l'autre joueur de les deviner et donc il
fait des propositions et est le premier
joueur c'est lui qui cache lui donne des
informations partielles sur est sûre sur
le code en lui disant combien de de deux
pions il a
de la bonne couleur et à la bonne place
et donc en fait c'est un jeu où au
départ ta ta ta 1296 possibilités et
puis j'ai chaque chaque jeu haché chèque
le coup que tu joues il ya une certaine
probabilité d'avoir des réponses et
chaque réponse de dix minutes on espace
de ddd possibilité donc il y avait
vraiment injuste un calcul d'espérance
d'information acquérir sur le sur le
code qui m'avait kim avait guidé dans
l'implémentation de ce jeu et il y avait
un petit peu de possibilités de machine
learning à cette époque donc je n'avais
pas du tout compris que c'était dit du
machine learning ne sais pas ce que
c'est mais en fait il ya une fonction
d'évaluations et la fonction
d'évaluation ont trouvé un petit peu
l'optimiser mais c'était pas que j'avais
ni les moyens calculatoire mais les
moyens intellectuels de penser optimiser
ses fonctions plus tard j'essaie
d'optimiser mais alors il s'est avéré
que entre temps le problème avait été
complètement résolu c'est un problème
qu'on peut résoudre par une combinatoire
de force brute et donc voilà donc mais
que quand j'ai fini de travailler sur ce
problème c'était plus et c'était plus
intéressant c'est des années plus tard
et il avait été totalement résolue par
parfois par d'autres temps qu'il fait
exactement on connaît exactement la
stratégie optimale
donc c'est un jeu qui a une combinatoire
suffisamment réduite comparé aux échecs
au bouveret mad et à des jeux plus plus
plus simple signac on a complètement
il ya d'autres chercheurs que moi qui
ont complètement explorer tout l'espace
de des stratégies possibles et qui ont
trouvé là là là la stratégie optimale à
celui je n'étais pas si loin notre était
légitime alors fait la veille des
méthodes de curbans informationnel mais
bon c'est pas moi qu'il qu'il aurait
fallu finalement hockey et en quelle
année
alors c'était quand j'étais en terminale
donc j'ai passé mon bac en 83 donc
c'était une date reculé du vote m cette
règle est donc après le domaine
informatique
donc après quand j'étais en thèse est ce
qui m'intéressait c'était de comprendre
pas mal les liens entre mathématiques et
informatique et gérard huet mais
proposer 2 de travailler sur un problème
sur lequel lui-même et son équipe
travaillent et à l'époque qui était de
représenter des démonstrations
mathématiques sur un ordinateur c'est à
dire d'être de en fait plus exactement
d'inventer un langage qui permettait de
représenter les fonctions mathématiques
et qui est un langage qui avait la même
rigueur
disons qu'un langage de programmation
qui était très loin de la langue
naturelle ou de la longue semi naturels
qu'on utilise pour représenter les
éléments sera pour écrire les
démonstrations mathématiques dans dans
la langue habituel enfin dans les livres
de mathématiques et c'est toujours le
domaine dans lequel je fais je fais de
la recherche
j'ai fait à rechercher aujourd'hui donc
ce ce domaine était un domaine que
gérard va pas vraiment créé mais disons
il là il est il est entré dans ce
domaine à une époque où il y avait
extrêmement peu de chercheurs donc y
aller dans cette direction qui
aujourd'hui c'est de venir des normes
domaine des normes il ya plusieurs
centaines de chercheurs dans le monde
qui qui travaillent sur ces sur ces
questions michel koch
oui alors le sait l'équipe de gérard qui
a développé le lycée lecoq moi j'ai
travaillé au début sur le logiciel coque
et puis après je me suis intéressé à des
problèmes un peu plus théorique donc je
me suis un peu éloigné de
l'implémentation de coqs soi même et
puis mélenchon revenu sur des questions
qui sont plus proches plus proche de
l'implémentation mais elle ma maman le
sujet de recherche qui est au coeur un
petit peu de ce que je fais en ce moment
avec mon équipe désormais c'est plus que
à côté de kokia d'autres systèmes qui
est qui existe donc un peu comme il ya
plusieurs langages de programmation il
ya java python s'est calmé
il ya plusieurs langages pour écrire des
démonstrations et ça c'est un petit peu
un problème au sens où dans l'histoire
des mathématiques on n'aime pas beaucoup
on n'a pas beaucoup aimé les époques où
il y avait différents différentes
notions de vérité mathématique c'est à
dire on aime bien l'idée que la vérité
mathématique et absolue alors c'est pas
quelque chose qui a été tout le temps le
cas par exemple quand on a découvert les
géométrie non euclidienne on a commencé
à voir certaines choses qui étaient
vraies dans certaines théories et les
fausses dans d'autres et puis merde mais
cette crise a été résolu en fait on a on
sait qu on a compris que ces différentes
théories ces différents systèmes
d'axiome et que le ski est absolu c'est
l'idée qu'une proposition soit vrai dans
une théorie axiomatique est donc cette
définition de vérité absolue donc on a
résolu ce problème
puis je le problème s'est reposé au
xxème siècle avec la démonstration a
découverte des la notion démonstration
constructive donc à nouveau il y avait
deux notions démonstration une notion
classique ne sont constructives
il y avait des choses qui était vrai
classiquement mais pas constructivement
et ça c'est quelque chose qu'on a
résolues relativement récemment en
s'apercevant que finalement les
démonstrations classiques et des 1500
constructive fonctionner très bien
ensemble l et s était pas du tout de
sorte de démonstration c'était je sais
pas un peu comme les protons et les
neutrons et puis finalement ça marche
mieux ensemble et en fait là le fait
qu'aujourd'hui on ait des démonstrations
qui sont exprimés dans des langages
formelle qu'ils soient traitées par des
parts des ordinateurs alors c'est à la
fois un énorme progrès pour tout un tas
de raisons qu'on pourra peut-être
discuter tout à l'heure mais ça pose à
nouveau un problème d'universalité delà
de la vérité mathématique
et donc ce sur quoi je travaille en ce
moment c'est plus l'idée de restaurer
cette universalité mathématiques en
montrant que même s'il ya des langages
différents
il ya des traductions entre entre
langage et c'est un problème qu'on a
résolues dans les langages de
programmation puisque on sait qu'on peut
programmer les même algorithmes entre
elles mêmes fonctions mais peut-être
mais mais mais malgré dans tous les
langages de programmation c'est là qu'il
ya des traductions possibles d'un
langage de programmation ou vers un
autre est ici c'est la belle idée de
montrer qu'il ya une forme
d'universalité de la vérité mathématique
parce que l'ia des algorithmes de
traduction des démonstrations d'un
langage la mer un autre les compilateurs
des des compilateurs le prof exactement
celle se sent comment travail du county
terre et c'est tu peux tu étais
expliquant de plus c'est la différence
entre un mode constructif des classiques
ou alors c c'est une problème du xxème
siècle vraiment c'est un problème qui
est apparu au tout début du 20e siècle
et qui est apparu
c'est triste mais bon c'est comme ça qui
est apparu comme une sous la forme d'un
conflit c'est à dire on sait qu'on s'est
pas rendu compte au début du xxème
siècle que il y avait dans cette cette
apparition de la notion même de
mathématiques ou de preuves constructive
un enrichissement de la notion de la
notion de démonstration du vocabulaire
mathématiques etc mais plus comme un
conflit alors j'ai d'abord le présenter
comme un conflit puisque c'est comme ça
que c'est que c'est apparu donc il ya
une une petite démonstration qu'on peut
faire dans sa tête on va pas l'écrire au
tableau puisqu'on n'a pas de tableau
mais vraiment plus longtemps on peut la
faire dans sa tête il faut juste
imaginer que tu es tu un train qui qui
va de paris à vienne
paris à constantinople et donc ils
s'arrêtent dans d'antan différentes
gares et on va dire qu'il ya des gars
dont tu connais les vents qui connaît le
nom je sais pas il va à nancy puis à
strasbourg et puis ensuite il va
s'arrêter plus tard à munich mais
imaginons qu entre strasbourg et munich
ont créé strasbourg est en france et
puis munich air et en allemagne
on va dire hors de france on va dire
qu'il me garde dont personne n'a jamais
entendu parler qui s'appelle l'utopie et
le train s'arrête donc à strasbourg à
utopia et et à munich et on se dit est
ce qu'il ya une dernière gare en france
dans laquelle le train s'arrête alors
dit forcément puisqu'il ya un moment il
est en france mais à un moment il est
hors de france est forcément une
dernière gare où il s'arrête avant de
passer la frontière
mais cette gare on peut pas savoir si
c'est strasbourg ou cissé l'utopia
puisqu'on sait pas de quel côté de la
frontière
utopia se situe donc on est capable de
faire un raisonnement que qui utilise un
principe le raisonnement qui s'appelle
le tir a exclu où on dit voilà ou bien
utopia et en france ou bien et aucun
n'est pas en france et si utopia et en
france à ce moment là la dernière gare
en france utopia puisque la gare
suivante et munich
et puis si la dernière gare puis utopia
départ en france à ce moment la dernière
guerre c'est trash strasbourg puisque ce
sera de voir 30 culte au pjak et la gare
suivante est pas et pas en france et on
s'aperçoit qu'il ya une propriété très
bizarre de cette démonstration sait
qu'on est capable de démontrer une
proposition qui est il existe une
dernière gare en france avant de passer
la frontière
mais en revanche on n'est pas capable de
dire de quelle gare il s'agit et ça
c'est quelque chose qui est apparu dans
les mathématiques et la fin du 19e
siècle c'est à dire toutes les
mathématiques depuis les babyloniens
jusqu'à ses skis et jusqu'au 19ème
siècle à chaque fois qu'on était capable
de dire qu'il existait un objet qui leur
fait certaines propriétés
on était capable de le construire et à
la fin du 19e siècle on abandonne un peu
ce set
cette particularité des démonstrations
mathématiques et c'est lié au fait qu'on
fait des mathématiques plus abstraite au
19e siècle et structure algébrique est
celle qui commence à poindre leur nez et
à ce moment là
il ya une réaction qui qui se construit
autour d'un mathématicien néerlandais
qui s'appelle bruère et bruère dit mais
non il quand on dit il existe un objet
il faut être capable de le construire
et si on n'est pas capable de le
construire c'est que on peut pas on peut
pas affirmer l'existence de cet objet
est donc ça ça amène à essayer de
comprendre où était le problème dans la
démonstration qu'on a qu'on a discuté
tout à l'heure et d'après brewer s'est
laissé l'idée qu'à un moment on a dit ou
bien utopia et en france ou bien et
obtient n'est pas en france donc ça
c'est un principe qui s'appelle le tir a
exclu et éboueurs no 10 est vraiment le
tir excuses qui est responsable du
caractère non constructible la
démonstration du fait qu'on puisse pas
trouver d'exemple alors qu'on peut qu'on
peut prouver l'existence ne pouvait
trouver un exemple et donc ça c'est un
ben brewer à dire il faut rejeter le
tiraille flux et donc à faire la
démonstration qu'on appelle des
démonstrations non constructives qui
n'utilisent pas le tir avec lui alors
forcément ça cette manière de formuler
des choses ne peut mener qu'à un conflit
puisque un certain nombre d'autres
mathématiciens dont par exemple
gilberte avaient construit leur carrière
sur l'or devait leur renommée à des
démonstrations qui utilisait le tiers
exclu et donc forcément il n'était pas
très content quand mme brewer leur a
expliqué que ces démonstrations étaient
fausses c'était le même le mot
qu'employé bauer s'est débaptisé c'est
complètement faux il faut pas publier
ces démonstrations les taxes téléphonie
bras et finalement il est sécurisé ssl
c'est faux là il disait que les il y
avait une confusion sur la nature même
de l'existence et la nature même du tir
a exclu thierry s'il pouvait s'appliquer
dans desquelles fini mais pas dans des
cars infinie donc si on a des gens
semblent infinies on peut pas dire ou
bien une chose est vraie ou bien ou bien
les fossiles faux ou bien montrer
qu'elle est vraie ou bien montrer
qu'elle est fausse mais on peut pas
juste
supposez que vous bien là ou bien
l'autre est vrai sans qu'on sache si
c'est là où si c'est l'autre et donc
forcément ça a mené une contre réaction
contre révolution qui ont dit non mais
le tir est exclu et toulouse est une
règle de raisonnement qui est tout à
fait valide donc si elle plaît pas à
bauer c'est son problème mais ça change
pas là la validité du raisonnement est
donc assez bizarrement on n'imagine pas
ça de la communauté scientifique mais il
ya des quasiment des injures qui volent
entre l'hérault 30 relais entre les
camps les deux camps le ce du maintien
mathématique constructive et ceux des
mathématiques non constructible des
mathématiques qu'on appelle classique
même si bon loll le beau et bien sûr
connoté parce que à l'époque la cité
mathématiques été constructives et ce
qu'on comprend pas c'est que en fait on
est en train de se battre sur des mots
puisque la manière dont on comprend
aujourd'hui la controverse c'est de dire
qu'il y a finalement deux significations
du mot il existe une signification qui
est la signification classique qu'on
pourrait traduire par il doit bien
exister où il n'est pas possible qu'il
n'existe pas et qui est acquis qu'elle a
le mode on parle dont on parle gilberte
et puis une autre signification du mot
il existe qui est celle de brouwer qui
est qui et il faudrait plutôt dire on
connaît et donc aujourd'hui il ya quand
on enseigne quand on enseigne ça on est
jeune voilà il ya deux quantifie catr
deux symboles différents deux
expressions différentes et à
l'expression il doit bien exister et on
connaît et voilà est donc en fait ce que
brewer a fait s'il est juste enrichit le
vocabulaire mathématiques en faisant une
distinction entre ces deux entre ces
deux significations du mot du mot il
existe mais mais bon allez à cette
époque ça s'est pas présenté comme ça ça
les personnes neal baer denis brewer
jamais vu que c'était juste deux mots
différents et qu'ils étaient juste des
espèces de ghonim est que
et il essaie vraiment de se battre pour
accepter ou refuser le tir exclu alors
que c'était vraiment pas la question la
question c'est est aujourd'hui canton il
ya ce qu'on appelle des logiques
oecuménique qui ont réconcilié les deux
notions de démonstration et dans
lesquels ben ya simplement deux
scientifiques at her il existe y en a
qui signifie qu'il vaut bien d'exister
et l'autre qui signifie qu'on connaît un
objet ce qui mettrait la même chose et
découvre tu parlais de compilateurs de
preuves c'était non non non alors non
pas du tout puisque c'est des cdd des
mots différents donc on peut pas
traduire une preuve de 12 questions des
ratés or m qu'ils nous montrent qu'il
doit bien exister un objet on peut pas
nécessairement le traduire dans les
affaires des verts des mathématiques
constructive alors cependant parfois on
peut faire mieux c'est à dire on a on a
juste une démonstration qu'il doit bien
exister un objet donc c'est en termes
plus traditionnels on a juste une
démonstration classique d'un d'un
théorème et on s'aperçoit qu'on peut la
rendre constructive donc il ya des
algorithmes de constructive isation
blessés des algorithmes qui marchent
parfois mais pas toujours accéder à
l'iguane de traduction partielle puisque
il ya certaines
il ya vraiment une d'une différence de
signification entre les deux entre les
deux mots et donc il n'est pas toujours
le cas qu'on peut qu'on peut traduire
qu'on peut renforcer la démonstration la
transforme en une démonstration classe y
font une démonstration constructif
si on peut pas ne peut pas et puis c'est
la vie c'est comme ça que je pense qu'il
faudrait clarifier cette notion de l'île
existe oui alors c'est une question qui
ce qui se pose qui est à partir de quel
de quel âge on peut enseigner ces
motions et aux écoliers aux collégiens
aux lycéens et disons il ya une
une une tradition une mathématique
disons qu'ils étaient celles de cesser
celle du 20è siècle qui était que de
dire que la construction effective des
objets n'était pas quelque chose
d'important
donc disons prenez les choses simplement
c'est une baisse qui avait gagné contre
brown et donc ont considéré que la
question de savoir si on pouvait
construire un objet effectivement ou pas
était une question secondaire devant la
question de savoir de pro b si il
existait ou non dans un monde abstrait
et c'était lié à une vision des maths
qui était une vision très très abstrait
très centrée sur des objets idéaux dont
on ne pouvait pas vraiment touché et
bien sûr la l'informatique a
complètement changé notre rapport 7 aux
objets mathématiques au sens où russie
on demande un informaticien si l'on dit
un informaticien qu' il existe une
solution à une équation la première
question qui va poser c'est comment la
calculer
donc il est assez naturel pour un
informaticien de se demander non pas
uniquement si un objet existe mais si on
peut avoir un accès à cet objet sont un
moyen de le calculer si un algorithme
qui peut être calculée et donc le
l'apparition de l'informatique dans les
années trente du xxème siècle donc pas
beaucoup après en fait la querelle qui
était dans les années 10 et dans les
années 20 et bien à peu à peu changé
là notre vision de notre rapport aux
objets mathématiques c'est des objets
aujourd'hui qu'on a davantage touché
avec avait avec les mains enfin disons
c'est c'est une image bien sûr on les
touche pas vraiment avec les mains mais
rooney rooney man tout cas construire
des programmes qui montrait ses objets
on on se pose la question quelle est la
milliardième décimales de pi alors il
suffit pas de prouver qu'il existe une
milliardième décimales de pi ce qui est
sans aucun câble mais après la calculer
c'est vraiment un problème tout à fait
tout à fait tout à fait différent et
donc ses idées de mathématiques
constructive qui au départ étaient
apparues avant l'informatique
brewer était pas du tout quelqu'un qui
s'intéressait à la technologie
ni assez c'est assez domaines de la
connaissance et de l'action mais disons
ça le développement de l'informatique a
remis au goût du jour les idées de brown
parce que c'est là l'informatique est
vraiment à une discipline ont construit
les objets pas une discipline on les
contemple dans leur beauté abstraite et
du coup a dit que tu étais pas mais
aussi en gagner dans l'enseignement des
maths et informatique
oui alors c'est un une espèce de hobby
pour moi donc c'est pas quelque chose
qui est un vrai travail de recherche que
j'ai que g bonnet mais que tout à
l'heure quand tu m'as demandé de
raconter un petit peu ma vie je t'ai dit
que pendant une période de ma vie
j'étais j'étais professeur à l'école
polytechnique et à cette époque je me
suis aperçu qu'il y avait vraiment une
différence de niveau et même une
différence de nature dans la
connaissance que les élèves et de
l'informatique et des autres sciences
donc pour des j'avais vraiment
l'impression de me retrouver face à un
amphi de deux étudiants qui avait 21 22
ans et de leur faire un cours qui aurait
dû être fait au cours moyen ou
quotidiennement au mans 5e donc et
expliquer à des personnes qui sont des
jeunes adultes la différence entre
atteste une boucle fort une boucle aux
arts etc
c'était il y avait quelque chose qui
n'allait pas en face c'était clairement
j'avais l'impression de faire un cours
de biologie et d'expliquer que le coeur
est à gauche et le foie et à droite à
moins que ce soit le contraire donc gt5
et
alors que mes collègues qui enseigne la
physique les bras tu es vraiment sur des
questions beaucoup plus beaucoup plus
pointu et donc je me suis interrogé
assez naturellement sur la la raison
pour laquelle s'était il s'était ainsi
bon il a raison n'était pas très
difficile à comprendre c'est qu'il n'y
avait pas dans les classes prépas qui
qui menait à l'école polytechnique dans
ses demandes informatiques et il n'y
avait pas au lycée non plus n avait pas
au collège non plus il n'est pas à
l'école non plus donc là où les élèves
que j'avais avait commencé à manipuler
les nombres à 6 ans et puis à manipuler
les équations du premier degré à 12 ans
et puis à manipuler les dérives et les
intégrales à 16 ans il commençait à 22
ans au niveau zéro les rudiments de la
programmation et donc je me suis dit bon
ça c'est pas quelque chose qui est qui
et qui est possible parce que après bien
entendu si on veut avoir une industrie
informatique en france ou en europe
si on veut avoir des chercheurs en
informatique si on veut avoir un faire
partie disons ben du développement de
l'informatique tels qu'ils se taisent
qui nous tels qu'ils se déroulent
aujourd'hui tel qu'il arrive aujourd'hui
enfin tels que des gens de construisent
aujourd'hui est plutôt au 21e siècle il
fallait il fallait changer ça au début
j'avais une vision très égoïste est très
centré sur ma personne donc je me suis
intéressé à ce qui se passait juste
avant que les élèves entrent à l'école
polytechnique et c'était dans les
classes prépa mais finalement je me suis
aperçu que même si la situation était un
peu moins en mettant à la fac puisque il
commence l informatique en première
année après le bac
en fait le problème est elle même et
j'ai décalé de deux ans et donc que ce
n'était pas juste et classes prépas
qu'il fallait changer mais aussi le
lycée et à ce moment là j'ai rencontré
pas mal de gens donc en particulier
maurice nivat qui était mort ici là
c'était le directeur de thèse de mon
directeur de thèse et qui avait organisé
une
un colloque avec à des mutations sur
cette question l'enseignement de
l'informatique donc comme il savait je
m'y intéressais il m'avait invité à
venir à venir il parlait petit à petit
c'est il s'est structuré un groupe de
gens qui qui a porté ce discours sur
l'importance de l'enseignement de
l'informatique avec un discours qui
s'est complexifiée avec le temps au
début pour moi c'était important que mes
étudiants connaissent de l'informatique
pour que je puisse leur enseigner
l'informatique à leur niveau mais après
je me suis aperçu que c'était important
aussi que tous les citoyens connaissent
un peu d'informatique
c'est à dire que tous les citoyens par
exemple sage sur la différence entre un
et laissé libre a réussi à la
propriétaire que lé lait tous les
citoyens comprennent l'importance des de
la notion par exemple de données privées
par opposition à données publiques
comprennent les questions de respect de
la vie privée enfin disons des questions
qui sont à la frontière de informatique
et société et que ça ça passait par an
par un enseignement de l'informatique
c'est à dire si on comprend vraiment pas
ce qu'il y'a une donnait ce qu'est un
algorithme aussi un programme ski un
ordinateur si tout ça c'est des mots
magiques s'est érodée on n'a pas du tout
les outils intellectuels pour comprendre
ce que c'est que la protection des
données
la cybersécurité le même envoyé un mail
et on arrive à envoyer un mail mais
qu'est ce qui se passe qui peut lire ce
mail comment est-ce qu'ils passent d'une
machine à l'autre
adieu un mail à ta grand mère et tout
d'un coup toc le mail art est dans la
boîte aux lettres de tagro versé comme
un truc extraordinaire il ya il avait 3
3 milliards de boîtes aux lettres sur
terre et hop qu'il arrivera bon dans la
boîte boîte aux lettres donc il ya
derrière des mécanismes des mécanismes à
comprendre et je me suis rendu compte
que tout ce qu'on disait en particulier
aux ados leur vivant fait attention sur
les sur les réseaux sociaux et s'ils
comprennent pas ce que ça veut dire
faire attention ils n'ont même pas idée
de ce à quoi il faut faire attention
donc on leur dit faites attention c'est
dangereux qu'on leur amène sa caisse
mais qu'ils fassent et donc
et donc c'était vraiment important dont
seulement d'enseigner
l'informatique dans tous ses aspects
scientifiques et techniques etc
comment on pense à l'enseigné pour des
gens qui vont devenir ingénieurs
techniciens etc
mais mais mais que ses connaissances
forcément enseigner d'une manière un peu
différente était vraiment utile à tous
et à tous les citoyens et donc du lycée
ont dépassé au collège puis à l'école
donc maintenant il ya on réfléchit même
à la manière dont on peut enseigner
l'informatique à l'école maternelle et
donc enseigner l'informatique des élèves
qui savent pas lire qui savent pas
qu'ils savent pas écrire qui qui ont une
[Musique]
une appréhension de la notion de
symboles qui est quand même très très
très rudimentaire et ben c'est quand
même des choses c'est quand même des
choses qu'on peut qu'on peut faire par
exemple il ya des objets découverts
salle des bronzes de l'informatique
échelonné c'est très peu il ya des
camions veux tu peux des mécanos qui
peut programmer et il ya juste quatre
flèches qui étudie une faille qui permet
aux camions d'aller tout droit et puis
des flèches qui devait permettre de
tourner et tu peux en programmer un
camion pour qu'il fasse un certain un
mouvement et est donc ça ça demande pas
bien sûr d'utiliser un ordinateur sa
demande pas utiliser un langage formel
ça n'ont pas utilisé la langue naturelle
mais petit à petit les élèves se
familiarisent avec l'idée qu' il ya un
moment où on programme le camion il ya
un moment où le camion roule et ces deux
moments qui sont distingués le moment du
développement du programme moment de
l'exécution du programme
et ça c'est des idées qui sont assez
naturel qui sont assez simple à
expliquer qu'on peut commencer à
expliquer dès la maternelle ou de délais
première année de l'école primaire puis
à plein d'autres choses qu'on peut faire
à l'école primaire d'ailleurs avec ou
sans ordinateur plus on parle d'enfants
qu'ils sont jeunes plus le lien entre
informatique et ordinateurs et des
contingents enfin moi moi et là
d'importance et puis après bien sûr au
collège c'est au collège c'est plus
facile de leur apprendre à programmer
puisque c'est le moment où ils
apprennent à la fois le langage de la
musique est un langage assez abstrait il
faut savoir qui est dans une mesure à
3,30 va être quatre fois tu peux m dos
noir et deux proches par exemple trop
binaire à trois temps ci ils apprennent
aussi le langage des équations sa
demande aussi d'être capable d'écrire à
décrire d'équations c'est être écrire
quelque chose à propos d'un objet que
l'on ne connaît pas donc il faut
imaginer un objet que l'on ne connaît
pas et même si on ne le voit pas et donc
ça c'est très lié en fait à ce niveau
d'abstraction que les les les jeunes à
athènes entre 10 et 15 ans disons c'est
c'est vraiment le bon moment pour
apprendre à programmer puis ensuite au
lycée on veut faire les choses plus
intéressantes par exemple commencé à
découvrir le domaine des preuves
formelles des machines de turin le
problème de la rai qui est pour le coup
peut revenir en gros bond au bon endroit
c'est à dire enfin de lycées ou en début
des études après le bac mais donc il ya
eu tout un tout une réflexion sur la
manière d'organiser un cursus
informatique qui va de 3 ans jusqu'à ce
qu'il va de la maternelle au doctorat et
donc ça ça a été pour moi l'occasion de
rencontrer de nouvelles personnes donc à
maurice nivat au début d'autres gens
comme jean pierre archambault jugé
jacques baudet et puis on a on a
construit des des curricula d'aider des
propositions on a écrit des manuels
enfin bon c'était une aventure alors
qu'ils aient pas qui est pas terminée
alors même maintenant on était la france
était plus ou moins dans les cancres
c'était en mai dernier dans les pays qui
ont cédé plus belles l'informatique et
maintenant on est dans les pays qu'ils
enseignent quasiment le mieux puisque
dans la dernière réforme de l'isf elle
acquit entrant en oeuvre cette rentrée
la rentrée prochaine donc la rentrée
2010 9 et l'encré
2020 parce qu'il faut penser que ton
podcast aura très certainement en 2030
il expliqué il faut expliquer à quelle
date on parle enfin à dire 2019 en 2020
donc maintenant il ya un enseignement de
spécialité donc un enseignement que des
élèves choisissent de suivre mais qui
peut aller jusqu'à quatre heures en
première et six heures en terminale donc
là il ya vraiment de quoi faire de la
vraie informatique on est sorti du cadre
juste la sensibilisation
mais voilà je pensais que quand on
aurait atteint ce point là on aurait
terminé le travail qu'on avait commencé
en fait non c'est le moment en fait ils
commencent c'est à dire il faut arriver
à faire vivre sa forme et les profs
créer une communauté de proft voilà donc
il ya énormément de il reste énormément
de travail des professeurs qui vont
cesser les professeurs de maths
non alors il ya un peu de tout c'est à
dire à terme ce qu'on espère c'est qu'il
y aura des professeur d'informatique
comme il ya des professeurs de maths et
de physique
il faudrait trop charger la barque d'un
seul professeur il si un professeur a
envie d'enseigner les maths il faut
plutôt le laisser enseigner les maths et
pas lui demander d'en céder des maths de
l'informatique et et tout un tas
d'autres choses et puis il ya une partie
de l'informatique qui est assez loin des
maths autant tout ce qui concerne les
algorithmes peut-être les langages aussi
il ya des liens assez forts avec les
mathématiques autant aussi concerts dans
la construction des constructions des
machines c'est beaucoup plus liées à la
physique le au semi conducteurs elle
affiche des semi conducteurs mais
également même la notion d'information
et les notions qu'ils heures plus tôt de
la physique que des maths c'est une
notion qui a une longue tradition de
d'émergence de la notion d'information
appart à la notion d'entropie qui aide
les notions de la physique du 19e siècle
l'eau croupie est temps aujourd'hui plus
ou moins définie comme l'information qui
nous manque sur un système est donc dans
toutes ces notions c'est pas forcément
des notions qui est prof de maths ont
envie d'enseigner
donc il ya à court terme parlons à long
terme une volonté de déformer des propos
des proches informatique il ya déjà un
capes d'informatique qui a été créée on
espère qu'il y aura une agrégation
d'informatique qui va être créée dans
l'année prochaine ou dans deux ans mais
il y avait bien sûr une phase de
transition
on peut pas passer d'un zéro prof 10000
profs comme ça en 2001 il faut les
mémoires faut les trouver
on n'a pas aujourd'hui dix mille
étudiants qui sont en master
d'informatique qui sont prêts à passer
le cap est donc il ya forcément une
montée en puissance qui va se faire
doucement et donc dans cette phase de
transition il faut faire un petit peu
fou tout bois c'est à dire à la fois que
l'ours et l'informatique sont enseignés
par les premiers profs titulaires d'un
diplôme d'enseignant d'informatique dont
du capes d'informatique on apprend
l'occurrence mais également des profs
qui sont volontaires et qui ont par eux
mêmes ou quand il était à la fac faire
un peu d'informatique et puis finalement
sont dirigés plutôt vers la physique ou
plutôt vers les matons plutôt vers la
musique ou plutôt j'ai découvert des
gens qui avaient fait d'informatique et
puis on s'est ensuite enseigné le dessin
la musique était alors des
statistiquement ils sont déjà observés
démographiquement c'est pas eux qui vont
résoudre le problème enfin bon ccc des
talents qui serait bête de ne pas de ne
pas utiliser aussi s'ils sont
volontaires pour pour faire ça et puis
le gros des troupes aujourd'hui c'est
beaucoup des profs de différentes
disciplines beaucoup de maths un peu de
physique un peu de techno et qui ont
décider par eux-mêmes de dessus une
autre formation donc l'éducation
nationale leur propose une formation
continue qui bien sûr à nos yeux est
insuffisante
bien sûr à leurs yeux est beaucoup trop
lourde et mais qui est voilà qui est un
compromis qui
qu'on peut faire aujourd'hui en
attendant qu'on recrute des vrais pros
de l'informatique entre guillemets ce
qui prendra plusieurs décennies c'est à
dire quand on regarde les créations de
matière au lycée qui ont eu lieu par le
passé
et bien quand on a introduit je ne sais
pas la biologie l'économie c'est vrai
qu'ils sont des matières relativement
récente
oui c'est à dire dans moins d'un siècle
d'ailleurs ces personnes alors on
s'aperçoit qu'il ya une phase de
transition qui n'est pas juste un bout
de temps c'est un c'est un gros c'est
une grosse machine qui transforme et
donc changer quelque chose au lycée
c'est pas du tout comme changer quelque
chose à la fac
un peu à la fac on fait un courant des
quatre ou cinq parfois on est l'équipe
de 10 tu as le numéro de téléphone de
toutes les collègues dans ton répertoire
et à la fac n'est pas ce dont parle de
deux de milliers le disait didier de
proc c'est toute une autre échelle c'est
une transformation du du monde qui se
passe et tout autre échelle dans
l'information est proche ça se passe
bien ça se passe bien et ça se passe mal
comme dans tout comme à chaque fois que
tu fais un cours il ya des gens qui qui
comprenait des gens qui comprennent pas
il ya des gens qui sont contents et qui
sont pas content il ya des gens qui
comprennent et qu'ils sont contents nos
petits pourquoi ils sont pas contents
auprès de paris qui sont contents quand
même donc il ya des gens beaucoup
beaucoup de deux profs en formation et
beaucoup de gens autour de sa découvre
que finalement l'informatique c'est pas
quelque chose qu'on peut apprendre cinq
minutes déjà ça c'est ça laisse aller
c'est une avec un facteur de progrès au
début le l'administration l'éducation
nationale avait l'impression qu'en en
quelques heures de formation pouvait
transformer un prof de maths ou un prof
de physique en prof d'informatique bon
et ça il s'avère que c'est sans doute
faux ça demande aussi si finalement on
recrute mes profs avec +4 à bac + 5 il
semble qu'une raison à lille il ya des
notions qu'il faut acquérir qu'il faut
écrire sur le temps voilà on a
aujourd'hui des profs qui sont bien
formés d'autres qui sont pas
suffisamment formés mais c'est pas grave
avant on n'avait rien du tout donc il
faut il faut il faut
par ailleurs est ce qu'on avait avant et
voilà c'est des pionniers comme toujours
les pionniers font un peu avec les
moyens du bord et il utilise plus ces
outils dont il dispose que les outils
dont ils ont besoin mais c'est pas grave
ça peut partir l'esprit pionnier et puis
petit à petit avec le temps c'est les
choses vont être plus plus cadré plus
plus régulière moins baroque plus de
classiques et voilà donc ça c'est
laisser la vie qui comme ça qu'est ce
qui est des pièges commencé monde de
l'informatique a évité structure oui on
a il y en a beaucoup et on les a un peu
rire un peu ils ont à la fac par exemple
on est un peu tomber dans tous les
pièges donc le principal piège c'est de
prendre un petit bout de l'informatique
et de croire que c'est l'informatique
dans son ensemble
donc c'est un des indes et bien con
qu'on remarque beaucoup en particulier
chez les profs de lycée qui ont ils
viennent d'une autre discipline donc
typiquement les profs de maths voit bien
l'informatique les sciences des
algorithmes c'est pas faux mais c'est
pas vrai non plus mais les profs de
technologies voit bien l'informatique
comme les séances des machines ce qui
n'est pas faux mais ce qui n'a pas
vraiment plu
certains profs qui sont plus rares voix
plus l'aspect informations lors sa
partition c'est par exemple le cas des
des proches bibliothécaire pour qui
l'informatique c'est d'abord les grosses
masses de données etc puisque c'est la
partie de l'informatique qui connaissent
également le web les les bases de
données en ligne etc
puis d'autres ont tendance à voir
l'informatique comme une science qui
serait purement une science des langages
en fait ces passages l'informatique
c'est la science à la fois des
algorithmes des machines de
l'information en fin de l'information et
des langages et donc il ya un biais qui
est qui est naturel et que on voit y
compris chez les lanceurs de la fac un
c'est pas du tout propre aux enseignants
au lycée
de croire que la partie de
l'informatique qui connaissent le mieux
est la partie la plus importante est en
fait il faudrait plutôt partir du
préjugé inverse c'est-à-dire de penser
que la partie comprenez mieux à la
partie des moins importants ce serait au
moins ça nous incite à elle est
enseignée d'autres d'autres d'autres
parties de l'inde autre partie de
l'informatique
donc c'est ça c'est un billet et puis
après il ya un certain nombre de faux
problèmes qui souvent se mettre en
travers d'un enseignement d'informatique
qui sont par exemple prennent du choix
du langage de programmation et donc on a
eu pendant très longtemps l'université
des combats entre les partisans alors
celle en fonction des époques c'était
pascal contre liste contre les langages
objet concret s'engage sans objet
quittons contre java et c est avec des
collègues qui ont parfois des divisions
un peu religieuse du choix du langage
mais finalement si on regarde ce qui
s'est passé dans la communauté de
recherche de sur les langages de
programmation
aujourd'hui il n'y a pas d' équipes de
recherche qui travaille sur un langage
de programmation donc il ya des ddd
fonctionnalités qu'on retrouve dans
certains langages et pas dans d'autres
et quand on enseigne la programmation il
faut centrer 7 son enseignement sur le
sens et fonctionnalités et donc ça ça a
permis qu'aujourd'hui à la fac c'est que
c'est qu'ils sont un peu plus ou moins
résolu on en fait les principes des
langages de programmation et plus la
programmation dans le langage machin ou
dans le langage truc et c'est d'ailleurs
un des beaucoup les étudiants ont
beaucoup poussé à aller dans cette
direction puisque
qu'on leur enseigne est la programmation
et une fois il ya un étudiant qui est
venu me voir qu'il était venu
m'expliquer pourquoi il avait pas choisi
mon cou alors je dis manset on a joué
beaucoup d'étudiants que je rejoue en
couture ont choisi mon cours par par
définition mais ça m'intéresse c'est
d'avoir la vie d'un étudiant qui avait
choisi pas choisir mon cours et il m'a
dit que son père lui avait appris de
langage de programmation à la fac je lis
ce que c'était j'ai même pas si j'ai
entendu parler de ces langages et que
c'était des langages qui avait
complètement disparu et que toute
l'énergie que son père avait investi
dans l'apprentissage de ces langages en
fait était perdu et je lis et d'une
excellente remarque c'était pour ça que
mon cours à moi n'était pas centré sur
un langage ou de en particulier mais
c'était sur la notion de langage de
programmation
bon après j'ai réussi à lui faire
changer d'avis et la prime au cours
quand même pour que c'était une petite
satisfaction pour moi mais mes dix ans
on voit bien là que c'est aussi les
demandes des étudiants de nous dire va
arrêter avec vos querelles de chapelles
essayer de vous enseigner des choses qui
sont utiles et qui est qui qui sont
durables qui nous ont permis de sortir
de ce que c'est que ces conflits un peu
stérile et au lycée c'est important de
faire la même chose c'est à dire c'est
important que les les profs de lycée
n'est pas l'idée que leur rôle c'est
dense et des pythons par exemple ça ça
serait dommage il utilise python penser
la programmation donc ça c'est un autre
un autre écueil écueils à éviter
il y en a un troisième qui est celui que
[Musique]
celui de la méthode pédagogique où on
commençait on peut pas enseigner
l'informatique au tableau noir ne peut
pas pour apprendre à programmer faut
écrire soi-même des programmes pour
apprendre des algues aurait il faut
soi-même les les construit avec
réfléchir et les implémenter donc on
peut pas on peut pas faire un cours
d'informatique entièrement au tableau
donc ça c'est vrai donc ça demande ça
c'est un effort énorme qu'on demande par
exemple au prof de maths qui ont
l'habitude de penser que les matches
font beaucoup au tableau même les
exercices de maths se font un câble
haute voix le nom il faut que les élèves
programme par emc
et c'est quelque chose hein c'est pas
quelque chose de totalement nouveau pour
eux mais qui a une certaine nouveauté
par exemple jusqu'à quand quand un élève
parent dans une mauvaise direction
on est à peu près sûr qu'il va pas
aboutir est ce qu'il faut le rattraper
après une minute ou et qu'il faut lui
laisser un an
ehret jusqu'à ce qu'ils découvrent par
lui même que c'était une impasse et
c'est quelque chose qui n'est pas du
tout simple ça dépend vraiment beaucoup
des cas ça dépend beaucoup des élèves et
des délais qu'on peut laisser et avait
longtemps et puis c'est pas grave parce
qu'ils ont leur apprendront beaucoup
plus comme ça et il n'a d'autre on sait
qu'ils ont envie de se décourager dont
ils ont eu beau essayer de les remettre
sur la voie et la bonne voie d' assez
vite même s'il faut pas le tard tout
s'est bien entendu voilà donc ça c'est
quelque chose de nouveau
et puis il ya donc il ya un bien qui est
de faire de vouloir faire des maths de
l'informatique comme des maths au
tableau qui à l'autre bien qui est de
dire que en gros il suffit de prendre un
bébé nous jeter dans le grand bain puis
va bien finir par apprendre à nager tout
seul et ça c'est pas vrai non plus on
sait que aussi par exemple on prend un
bébé qui n'a jamais interagit avec
personne et qu'on met dans un caisson
étanche alors bien sûr il ya des des
considérations éthiques
mais si on le fait on fait qui est la
probabilité qu'ils réinventent la
mécanique quantique et la machine de
turing est faible donc donc il ya aussi
quelque chose dans l'enseignement de
l'informatique et transmissif allez
c'est pas vrai que les élèves vont
retour et découvrir par eux-mêmes
est ce qu'ils font des projets et non
pendant d'un projet comme voisin
l'activité de recherche et une partie
qui consiste à documenter sur ce que les
autres ont fait et donc c est tout d'un
coup on s'aperçoit qu'on réhabilite le
prof au tableau noir alors pas forcément
au tableau noir marron réhabilite la
fonction du prof non pas comme coach qui
va comme accompagnateur du projet d des
élèves mais vraiment comme la source de
savoir et qui vient qui qui qui qui lui
qu'il doit transmettre aux élèves et ça
c'est ça c'est quelque chose qui est qui
et qui a
difficile à gérer on voit des profs qui
s'imagine en étant uniquement des
accompagnateurs de progrès qui doit
uniquement dans le transmissif et puis
le le l'enseignement de l'informatique
c'est un mélange des deux et donc c'est
dur à trouver ça a été dur c'était
extrêmement dur à trouver pour nous à la
fac ou dans les écoles d'ingénieurs
on a fini par mois je me souviens de
discussions interminables pour savoir
s'il fallait deux heures de cours et
trois heures de td ou trois heures de
cours et deux heures de td ou pas
d'accord du tout pas de t d du tout
autre enfin il y avait tous les tous les
points de vue aurait fini par trouver
l'espèce de sinon de consensus au moins
de compromis
et le compromis à trouver sans doute
différent au lycée ça ne peuvent pas
forcément le même et il est sans doute
différent au collège de ce qu'il est au
lycée aussi et donc ses services et aux
profs qui sont sur le terrain de le
trouver et on peut discuter avec eux on
peut pas le faire à leur place des
vosges
voilà donc ça c'est aussi mode des
difficultés c'est un autre un autre
écueil dans le qu'il faut éviter
d'occident donc là on parle d'un prix
d'enseignement pour les élèves de moins
de 20 ans ce qui a besoin de 6 une
formation continue plus tard oui c'est
une question qui se pose dans le monde
dans lequel on est où dit on vit une
révolution technique
alors on a vécu d'autres évolutions
techniques par le passé mais pas sans
doute pas de cette ampleur et pas avec
autant de gens donc si tu prends une
révolution technique comme celle de
l'écriture il faut bien admettre que
pendant deux trois mille trois cents ans
avant jésus-christ jusqu'à jusqu'au
19ème siècle l'écriture concerne qu'une
toute petite partie d'un delà de la
population donc
donc il ya il ya cette révolution qui
fait qu'il ya des gens qui savent écrire
et d'autres et d'autres non aimer ça pas
l'air d'être un problème si grave
puisque il ya une petite caste de script
qui alertent d'écrire pour les autres ça
a l'air de suffire
il ya une autre évolution qui est
celle de l'alphabet l'kid vrai coup a
permis à plus de gens d'écrire puis
celle de l'imprimerie qui a permis à
plus de gens d'avoir des des livres chez
eux
il faut bien voir que l'écriture jusqu'à
l'an priori c'était quasiment rien enfin
c'était c'était ça nous a permis
d'accéder au texte de platon et ses
armées mais en termes de en terme social
etc
il ya le nombre de gens qui écrivaient
qu'ils disaient tu es très faible dons
de livres à taux très faibles et donc
c'est vraiment l'imprimerie sans doute
la la la la révolution la plus la plus
proche
et ça ça c'est trois révolutions
techniques qui sombre dans le domaine de
la technique de l'échangé d'informations
et puis après il ya des révolutions
techniques comme la machine à vapeur
c'est à mais qui sont qui sont moins
liées qui est qui qui ont moins voir
avec la révolution convient qu'on vit
aujourd'hui
et donc quand on vit une révolution
comme celle là bas bien entendu ça crée
un fossé de génération et il est
important que en plus de la de la
formation initiale
hong hong et une formation continue donc
pour pour pour pour les gens
tout au long de leur vie est bon alors
ce qui crée des situations nouvelles
aussi donc il ya des situations il ya
une situation très difficile à gérer où
il ya des gens qui ont eu l'idée fausse
mais bon pour une fois que c'est drôle
dans leur tête c'est ça sert à rien de
dire que c'est faux qui a eu l'idée qu'
il fallait apprendre quand on était
enfants ou ados ou jeunes adultes et
puis après que ça qu'on avait appris
c'était bon on a le plus besoin de rien
à prendre quasiment fin je caricature un
peu
alors ça c'est des gens qui sont assez
des tice est assez difficile d'aller
gens expliqué maintenant il faut il faut
il faut se remettre
il faut se remettre à apprend il y en a
d'autres qui soient prêts à prendre mais
qui n'arrivent pas à trouver du temps ou
qui arrive pas à trouver de l'argent et
ça c'est ce qui est intéressant c'est
que la révolution informatique c'est
aussi une révolution qui fait qu'on a
beaucoup plus de temps libre
on a beaucoup moins de
nécessité de travailler un exemple que
je cite dans le livre le temps des
algorithmes que à écrire et que serge
abiteboul c'est le fait que en france
sur 66 millions de français avec 42
millions qui travaillent pas à sauver
beaucoup 42 millions mais il faut penser
qu'il y en a 12 millions qui ont moins
de saison 12 me ou encore plus de 65 ans
en eurasie bourse est normal que des
enfants de moins de 16 ans travaille pas
on va pas envoyer les enfants à la bible
comme au 19e siècle mais bon c'est
relativement récent et il ya beaucoup de
gens qui ont entre 16 il ya 12 millions
de gens au site entre 16 et les 65 ans
qui travaillent pas non plus et essai
j'en sais beaucoup d étudiants
belencontre plus que 16 ans mais qui
sont encore encore étudiants et donc
disposer en plus il ya après il ya un
certain nombre de chômeurs anti
apartheid à la population active mais
pas telle population active occupée mais
donc il ya une question qui est que ce
qu'on va faire de tout ce temps libre
que là que la l'informatique nous nous
donne vous tous tank informatique libère
donc un exemple un exemple de ça qu'on
vit quasiment 7 ab ou disons le l'année
dernière à cette année c'est le fait
qu'il y avait 200 milles caissiers
caissières dans les supermarchés donc on
peut dire des caissières parce que
c'était à 99 % des femmes et aujourd'hui
et si on remplace toutes ces écoutes ses
caissières par des caisses automatiques
il ya deux cent mille personnes qui tout
d'un coup se retrouvent privés de
travail
ça pose une question est ce que il faut
qu'elle soit privée de travail et primé
de revenus ou qu'elle soit privée de
travail mais qu'on continue à leur
donner un revenu puisque finalement
continuer à écrire la même quantité de
richesse pour ça ça pose des questions
d'organisation des sociétés qui sont
sans nouvelles mais une réponse possible
c'est de dire c'est 200 mille personnes
une chose qu'elle pourrait faire de
leurs journées c'est apprendre quelque
chose d'autre c'est compliqué parce que
ce que ça peut être des personnes qui ne
marchent plus envie de
des choses j'ai essayé d'apprendre très
m'a pas beaucoup plus donc je peux me
remettre maintenant mais on s'aperçoit
que globalement sans se focaliser sur
une personne ou une autre globalement on
a une des transformations techniques qui
font qu'on dégage beaucoup de temps
libre
donc ce temps libre on n'est pas obligé
de ne pas obliger de passer directement
de l'usiné à la fac un sait pas on va
pas transformer les les facs en usine
mais une possibilité c'est que des gens
se disent je décide d'apprendre de
nouvelles choses et aujourd'hui quand on
discute dans les entreprises avec des
directeurs des ressources humaines des
fréquences et des formations longues
ils pensent souvent des formations qui
sont deux jours quatre jours quelques
jours c'est la formation il ya deux
jours c'est la formation pas longue il
faudrait qu'on aille vers un monde où on
peut dire bah voilà pendant les trois
ans qui viennent
je vais recommencer des études d'autres
choses et extra normale et qu'on garde
un salaire on regarde la revenus qu'on
garde une couverture sociale pour
continuer à cotiser pour sa retraite
enfin bon tout un stade des choses qui
sont importantes quand on est dans la
vie active mais qu'on permette qu'on
permette à des gens non pas juste
d'aller faire informations sur tel ou
tel logiciel pendant deux jours mais
pourquoi pas d'aller passer une licence
d'informatique à la fac saint louis où
les cent pas autre chose nous allons
produire plein de plein de choses qu'on
peut lui apprendre
donc c'est vraiment un rapport au savoir
complètement différent qui est en train
de s'instaurer qui a du mal à
s'instaurer puisque les les universités
sont pas dupes organisé pour saler les
le monde du travail et pas du toril
c'est pour ça c'est très bizarre pour un
ingénieur ou un technicien ou à un
employé de dire voilà je prends trois
ans de vacances pour aller refaire des
études mais c'est quelque chose qui
devrait être possible
c'était peut-être quelques occasions
c'est être plus là non ouais je sais pas
je sais
je suis pas absolument sûr parce que il
ya vraiment une question de dette
sociale et enfin de prise en charge de
ces personnes par les sociétés donc les
états unis sont pas spécialement en
avance sur l'europe sur cette question
de deux présences prise en charge des
personnes non directement productive
papa par la société mais bon il ya très
certainement des choses qui se passent
dans différents pays qui sont
intéressantes à regarder puisque tous
les pays d'europe où tous les pays
développés même les pays en voie de
développement en fait sont confrontés
aux mêmes ou même question est donc
c'est intéressant de voir que chacun
découvre un bout de la solution de son
côté sans que personne ait encore une
vision très cohérente de ce que sera
cette société de la connaissance dont
tout le monde parle mais bon on ne sait
vraiment à quoi elle ressemble qu'à ta
s'apprêtait de la vulgarisation
[Musique]
alors c'est c1
une activité que j'avais j'ai commencé à
écrire de la delà des textes de
milliards et nation des livres de
vulgarisation au début de ma carrière
alors c'était quelque chose qui était
perçu comme étant un peu bizarre par mes
collègues puisque les mêmes visions du
monde où quand on était jeunes
chercheurs que la recherche ou la
recherche et d'enseignement
et puis c'était juste quelques années
avant de prendre sa retraite que ont
commencé à s'adresser au grand public et
il me semblait au contraire que ça
rejoint pas mal de la discussion
précédente
il me semblait au contraire que la
vulgarisation ou la médiation comme on
dit aujourd'hui devait être une par une
partie intégrante de du travail du
chercheur
ça veut pas dire que chaque chercheur
doit faire nécessairement de la
médiation puisque si on vient à l'idée
que chaque chercheur doit faire et de la
recherche et de l'enseignement de la
diffusion
vera vers l'industrie et la diffusion
d'un grand public etc s'aperçoit qu'il
ya trop de tâches pour femmes chercheurs
mais disons qu'une part non négligeable
des chercheurs y compris les jeunes
chercheurs s'intéressent aux questions
de corruption de médiation est ici les
enjeux étaient un peu les mêmes donc on
peut pas imaginer qu'il y ait un une
communauté scientifique qui développe
des deux nouvelles idées et qui ne
partagent pas avec avec avec le plus
grand nombre alors sa peau deux types de
problèmes ça pose un problème que à
supposer que ça marche on aurait une
espèce de tourny voir avec des
scientifiques qui sont en avance de 50
ans le reste du monde et ça ça serait
pas bien mais surtout cette communauté
serait très fragilisée c'est à dire on a
cette image j'ai jamais compris si elle
était vraiment réel où c'était
reconstruction on a cette image un petit
peu des moines dans les monastères à la
fin du moyen-âge qui continue à parler
en latin et à écrire en latin et puis
une espèce de culture vernaculaire qui
apparaissait avec des gens qui
écrivaient en italien et que et que
cette culture vernaculaire a
complètement effacé la culture médiévale
qui existait mais c'est sans aucune
vision un peu caricatural mais en tout
cas en tant qu'image elle doit elle doit
nous être
elle doit nous amener à réfléchir aux
risques qu'il y as d'avoir une
communauté scientifique petit qui parle
son propre langage qui n'est pas compris
qui n'est pas comprise du reste de la
population
et bien entendu cette communauté
scientifique sera elle même très très
fragile
alors il ya plein de moyens de partager
le lait n'a connaissance avec
avec le reste de la société
l'enseignement l'éducation et en est un
mais il me semblait qu'il était
important que ça prenne aussi d'autres
voies qui sont plus ouvertes vers plus
de gens avec la médiation la
vulgarisation était en fait partie voilà
donc ça c'est un petit peu l'histoire
que je raconte et a posteriori puisque
ce qui m'a amené à écrire mon premier
livre était des considérations beaucoup
plus personnel et beaucoup plus égoïstes
ils ont comme comme cela racontait
j'étais déjà intéressé par les sciences
quand j'étais au lycée horizon oui c'est
au collège pas beaucoup aux lieux aux
riceys et donc à cette époque j'avais
une certaine frustration de que ça va
pas plus vite
donc j'avais vraiment envie de devenir
chercheur et puis l'idée de passer trois
ans dix et cinq ans elle à la fac et
senna vont pouvoir commencer à faire la
recherche ne semblait ça me semblait
très nom est donc le le le la solution
que j'avais trouvé c'était de lire de la
vulgarisation d'aller opérer des
découvertes recherche elle je pensais à
l'époque la cité des sciences n'existait
pas au coeur enfin bon disons dans les
musées des sciences d'un côté et puis
les les livres de vulgarisation ou les
journaux de vulgarisation la revue les
découvertes pour la science était
vraiment des des trucs était important
pour moi en tant qu' en tant que
scientifique en devenir est donc assez
naturellement ça va c'est pas beaucoup
réfléchi quand je suis devenu moi-même
chercheurs de me dire bah c'est naturel
que si j'ai bénéficié de ce partage de
connaissances de la part d'autres
chercheurs que maintenant je fais partie
je partage moyenne mais mais mais mais
propre connaissance avec d'autres et bon
j'ai jamais une vision aussi un peu
naïve que j'allais écrire un livre avec
eux
60 millions personnel et l'a jeté et
venir donc ça c'est pas tout à fait
comme ça que ça s'est produit
mais aujourd'hui grâce à des gens comme
toi et brasse grâce au web
on s'aperçoit que ce rêve qu'on avait
20e ci avec la fin du xxème siècle quand
j'ai commencé à écrire des livres de
toucher un public vraiment vraiment très
vaste et bien finalement c'était un ami
juste 20 ans d'avancé puisque vingt ans
plus tard c'est ce qui commence à se
produire 10 ans avec avec youtube heures
comme toi / sur le web mais aussi par
exemple un écoute ipdia c'est un
exercice que j'arrive pas à faire et que
je demande toujours beaucoup de gens de
coeur d'essayer d'imaginer la parle dans
tout ce qu'ils savent quelle est la part
qui viennent occuper lieu il ya des
choses qu'on a appris à l'école
bien entendu c'est des choses qui sont
plus structurés c'est des connaissances
qui sont vraiment opérationnel qu'on
sait utiliser professionnellement mais
tout ce qu'on sait sur je ne sais pas
tous les sujets dont on n'est pas un
expert je lis l'histoire le la biologie
etc
en ce qui me concerne a touché
énormément de trucs que j'ai appris que
j'appris dans wikipédia beaucoup de
wikipédia est aussi un vecteur qui a
peur c'est à la fois une encyclopédie
c'est beaucoup de choses à la fois une
encyclopédie louvre ou le livre du
routard etc
mais c'est aussi beaucoup un médium de
médiatisation de dos médiation
scientifique con qu'on présente pas
souvent comme ça mais je pense qu'il
faut un peu le même métier que toi c'est
un peu les concurrents mais ouais j'en
profite souvent ces cadors de ce qu'ils
font ça que servent action en confiance
de sir terme que je alors ça c'est une
évolution culturelle que j'ai remarqué
il ya des gens quand ils entendent dans
la conversation un mot qui ne
comprennent pas qu'ils ne connaissent
pas qui ont tendance à demander ce que
ça veut dire qu'ils ont ou qui reste sur
deux prestations qui se disent mais
voilà on a employé un mot que je connais
pas je sais pas ce que ça veut dire je
suis perdu et le fait d'avoir un
dictionnaire déjà un dictionnaire papier
permet d'aller chercher dans le
dictionnaire papier mais quoi comme tu
le disais quand tu es une conférence en
général qui doit l'être pas le petit
robert pour chercher les boucs tu que tu
comprendrais pas et le fait d'avoir le
dictionnaire un dictionnaire sur ton
ordinateur ou son téléphone te permet de
tout de suite comprendre la
signification d'un mot et puis et puis
de continuer la discussion de continuer
ou à écouter une conférence ou quelque
chose comme ça donc beaucoup le web nous
a beaucoup appris la lettre mais touche
pause et on est on est perdu il ya
quelque chose qu'on comprend pas on fait
on arrête on regarde d'autres choses on
revient ce qui est un rapport à la
connaissance qui est très très différent
du rapport qu'on avait du rapport à la
connaissance qu'on avait à l'école ou
voilà quoi y'a un prof qui parle c'est
difficile de mettre sur la touche pause
en faisant de médiation du roi est ce
que tu t'es senti
enfin 710 été valorisés au pénal est
taquin le chercheur en fait je me suis
pas vraiment posé la question c'est à
dire je me suis pas début je me suis pas
de me suis pas dit je si je passe du
temps à écrire un livre ça sera du temps
que j'ai passé en moins faire de la
recherche et où elle est née si j'écris
un livre avec eux je suis célèbre ça va
accélérer ma carrière c'était pas du
tout les questions que je me suis posée
parce que pour moi c'était vraiment une
démarche naturelle dont je rêvais pas
imaginer de faire autrement donc j'ai
pas l'impression que c'était vraiment un
choix donc c'était juste une une pente
naturelle à à suivre après j'ai je
dirais pas que ça m'a pénalisé mais ça
aurait pu me pénaliser si j'avais fait
que ça par exemple donc cessé à une dune
d une des discussions que j'ai souvent
avec des des jeunes collègues qui font
de la médiation je le redis fait
attention que si le fait que la
médiation ça peut ensuite tout pénalisé
dantin dans ta carrière malheureusement
parce que on a aussi besoin de gens qui
font la médiation bien et de manière
professionnelle et c'est donc
donc je pense qu'il faut que ça reste
une part raisonnable de son de son
activité et donc j'irai plutôt que sama
ça m'a aidé dans ma carrière mais ça m'a
aussi beaucoup aidé parce que ça m'a
amené à me poser des problèmes que je me
serais pas posé sinon et ça c'est
quelque chose qui était donc je vais pas
du tout conscience au début et je me
souviens très bien du moment où l'on ait
pris conscience
c'était un moment où j'ai essayé
d'écrire le mont livre zéro c'est à dire
avant de le premier livre de médiation
que j'ai publié ses terres à nis dans la
collection d'obino qui s'appelait
logique et avant ça j'avais écrit un
autre livre qui ait jamais été publiés
qui était une espèce de brouillon de ce
qu'est devenue la logique est content
quand j'écrivais ce ce ce texte
je me souviens très bien j'étais à
austin au texas où j'ai fait une partie
bon de mon post doc et il y avait un
moment il y avait deux chapitres il y en
avait un qui paraissait simple à écrire
et puis l'autre qui paraissait compliqué
je n'essaie pas normal parce que en
théorie ça devrait être deux fois et
même chapitre et donc je me suis aperçu
qu'il y avait 1 1
une manière de présenter les choses dont
les livres qui s'adressait aux étudiants
qui étaient pas la plus simple et pas la
plus naturelle et que ça on n'arrivait
pas à la présente on n'arrivait pas à
présenter cette notion de manière simple
parce que on avait il ya un an après le
scientifique fonda en dessous corps est
pas résolue et donc que mon ce n'était
pas très grave pour quand quand on avait
un public captif d'étudiants on pouvait
très bien faire quelque chose qui est un
peu plus compliquée que dans le cas
précédent qui était un peu plus
compliqué que ce qu'on aurait pu faire
mieux entendre la médiation je me disais
les lecteurs de médiation sont des
vieillards isation de livres de
vulgarisation sont beaucoup moins
tolérants que que les étudiants
puisqu'ils sont pas captif même s'il a
envie de re claudie pas faire autre
chose et est donc là il faudrait
vraiment que j'arrivais l'expliqué
simplement et ça ça va amener à premier
problème de recherche
c'est le premier problème de recherche
qui a était issue d'une volonté de
transmettre
après c'est pas dans ma carrière ça
m'était arrivé deux ou trois fois
donc ça n'a pas été le moteur essentiel
de ma carrière que d'essayer de résoudre
le problème scientifique qui se poserait
à moi parce que j'arrivais pas à faire
de la médiation de la manière dont
j'aurais voulu mais ça a été à plusieurs
moments d d d incitation à essayer de
résoudre des problèmes de recherche que
je ressente pas regarder sinon je sais
tout le temps les prime de recherche qui
venait à simplifier des cadres à voir
les choses d'une manière plus plus plus
plus clair plus général et donc c'est
après une tendance qui est prise dans
mon travail de recherche d'essayer de
comprendre des cadres un peu généraux de
dauphin de focaliser juste sur un objet
mais c'est de regarder ce qui se passe
est un peu autour et ça je pense que le
la prise de recul que le travail de
médiation demande m'a beaucoup aidé à
aller dans cette direction
ok le problème en question est
compliquée dans sa folle oui enfin c'est
pas celle à qui la question était qu' il
y avait une île et où toute une famille
de théories en logique qui s'exprime
dans un même langage que qu'on appelle
la logique des prédicats et pour toutes
les théories qui s'exprime dans dans ce
langage on a une des notions un peu
standard en particulier une notion de
modèle et j'imagine que tu as dû
expliquer ça dans une noté vidéo et dans
une théorie particulière qui s'exprime
pas dans ce langage mais le son modèle
était plus compliqué donc c'est là une
théorie qui s'appelle la théorie des
types la tour du type simple et je me
disais mais pourquoi est ce que on a
besoin de faire un chapitre à tard sur
les modèles de la théorie des types sont
alors qu'on pourrait être juste dire
c'est des modèles comme les autres et on
s'est aperçu que c'est parce que la
théorie des titres simples n'était pas
exprimé pendant dans la musique des
prédicats qui est elle
le cadre où on pouvait avoir cette
notion de modèle un peu
standard je me suis dit mais est-ce que
c'est impossible de l'exprimer est-ce
que ça va poser en difficulté etc
et là je me suis aperçu qu'il y avait un
certain nombre d'autres chercheurs qui
s'était posé cette question avant qu'ils
avaient apporté des réponses partielles
certains avaient quasiment fait le
quasiment fait le truc et ça ça a
complètement changé le regard que
ensuite j'ai porté sur cette théorie en
particulier qui me semblait beaucoup
moins exotique et beaucoup moins
marginal et le 1-1 travail que j'ai que
j'ai faits qui n'est pas un travail
stable est difficile parce que quand je
lui dirai était déjà bien débroussaillé
par d'autres c'était d'exprimer la
théorie des types simple comme une
théorie comme les eaux dans la logique
des prédicats mais voilà puis je me suis
finalement la logique des prédicats
c'est un cadre dans lequel il faut
arriver toutes les théories donc c'était
cette volonté de généralisation qui de
de poser des cadres suffisamment vaste
pour que beaucoup de connaissances il y
entre qui au départ était motivé par une
volonté d'être clair d'être simple de ne
pas multiplier les chapitres dans mon
livre
et puis qui finalement est devenu aussi
l'attitude on recherche donc de ce point
de vue là je veux dire que la médiation
va beaucoup aider à faire de la
recherche puisque je pense qu'il
faudrait ptet médiation
la question est pas con c'est pas juste
une question d'offre disons il ya une un
équilibre entre l'offre et la demande en
médiation il y avait aussi beaucoup de
livres de médiation qui sont écrits et
qui trouve pas de public donc il faut il
faut il faut prendre compte faut prendre
ça en compte si on vendait aujourd'hui à
chaque chercheur d'écrire un livre
chaque année on aurait des montagnes de
livres que personne des liens et donc il
faut avoir cette il faut avoir ça en
tête
mais je crois que on devrait
s'interroger sur la manière de deux
d'augmenter le le désir de sciences
bon alors après c'est toujours pareil
quand il quelque chose qui te plaît
c'est toujours mystérieux comprendre
pourquoi ça plaît pas aux autres c'est
un des grands biais de la manière dont
les voyons le monde mais j'ai
l'impression qu'il ya beaucoup de gens
qui parlent et on pourrait lire des
livres de médiation scientifique qui le
font pas et qu'ils ne font pas parce
qu'ils n'ont pas envie mais aussi mais
beaucoup parce qu'ils pensent qu'ils
vont rien comprendre donc
donc ça c'est une difficulté il y en a
aussi qui n'en n'ont pas envie parce
qu'ils ont une image de la science qui
est dégradée on n'aime pas les sciences
et si on essaye de comprendre pourquoi
il n'a pas l'aura s'ils ont une image
exacte de ce que sont les sciences et
qui n'aiment pas ça avant ça c'est leur
revient sur scène leur liberté mais s'il
n'aime pas et s'ils ont fait ce qu'ils
ont une image déformée de ce que sont
les sciences à ce moment là on se dit
qu'il ya sans doute à un problème est un
problème qu'on pourrait cocon pour
essayer de résoudre
et moi je suis assez critique sur un d
un point d'enseignement des sciences
dans le monde entier mais
particulièrement en france qui n'est pas
un point central disons je ne jette pas
vraiment là la pierre aux enseignants
parce que c'est c'est vraiment pas le
centre peut leur de l'or que leur métier
mais je m'aperçois que le le fait de
d'utiliser la connaissance qu'elle soit
scientifique d'ailleurs ou ou
littéraires comme un critère de
sélection sociale pose un vrai problème
d'accès ensuite ensuite à la
connaissance alors l'exemple typique de
sas et tu vas faire une conférence au
pays les découvertes ou ou dans un temps
s'amuse et des sciences
combien de magnifiques arènes à bordeaux
et ailleurs
et puis au moment des questions tu
t'aperçois que les gens le topo délais
qui sont certes ont exposé t pose des
questions sur une espèce de traumatisme
précoce ou un jour leur prof de maths ou
à reprendre de ceux ci leur a dit si
leur a dit ça alors à donner une
mauvaise note alors qu'ils avaient fait
l'exercice etc et on dit c'est quand
même bizarre que alors que tu viens leur
apporter sur un plateau les joyaux de la
science contemporaine et il te parlent
de leur misérable est conscient du
premier degré quand il était quand il
avait cinq ans ou dix ans quinze ans et
vit il ya juste un problème qu'il soit
resté scotché sur cette représentation
des sciences alors que ils ont à leur
présentation des sciences aurait pu
aurait pu évoluer et être plus plus plus
ouverte vers les cimes en cas de casse
on est donc là on est bien obligé de se
dire que chaque fois qu'on met une
mauvaise note un étudiant
potentiellement ont créé un une
situation où cet étudiant après va
garder toute sa vie un une relation
conflictuelle temps du temps avec avec
les sciences
alors est-ce qu'on peut mettre des
bonnes notes à tout le monde sans doute
c'est pas être tolérant sur les notes
c'est par exemple
bon bien entendu il ya une limite à ça
à supposer qu'on donne gratuitement les
diplômes à tout le monde à l'université
ou disons qu'on supprime la notion
diplôme et que l'on dise des étudiants
vont à l'université uniquement pour
apprendre apprendre des choses
bon on s'aperçoit qu'il ya il ya deux
limite à ça par exemple quand je prends
l'avion je suis content que pilote et un
diplôme de pilote et je suis content que
il ya des personnes à qui on n'a pas
d'eau on n'est pas donnée le diplôme de
pilote et qu'ils ont ce qu'ils
conduisent pas l'avion qui ne sont pas
en train de me faire voler l'avion dans
lequel je me trouve donc c'est pareil
quand je vais à l'hôpital j'espère que
le médecin qui va me soigner il a
vraiment passé ses examens pour devenir
chirurgien ou quoi et qui n'a pas eu à
se découvrir
qui va passer improvisé chirurgien donc
c'est bien entendu on peut pas tout à
fait abstraction de ça et puis l'autre
chose c'est qu'on s'aperçoit quand on
fait des courses en examen mais bon que
les étudiants manquent d'une des
objectifs concrets et donc ils sont un
peu perdus face à un une immensité de
savoir qu'il ne t'y le pied sans fond et
ils savent pas très bien le jusqu'où il
faut acquérir des notions alors que si
on leur donne un objectif qui est
d'avoir la moyenne à l'examen c'est
c'est un quelque chose qui structurent
un clip qui structurent un court mais
cependant une fois qu'on a dit ça on
s'aperçoit que si on fait un cours et
qu'on met moins de la moyenne deux tiers
de l'amphi où à deux tiers de la classe
bon ça veut dire que ou bien le court
était pas bon ou l'examen n'était pas
adaptée aux courts
voilà donc on peut pas être tout le
temps on me prête autant sanctionner les
élèves leur mettre des mauvaises notes
et sanctionner les étudiants l'orma des
mauvaises notes comme si c'était normal
ils ont le j avais une manière un petit
peu de faire réfléchir les étudiants là
dessus et beaucoup d'étudiants considère
que vont ils ont 18 sur 20 c'est une
bonne note alors beaucoup parce qu'ils
sortent d'un système où on mettait des
notes très inférieur à 18 sur 20 mais je
leur disais même 18 sur 20 ça veut dire
qu'il ya 10 % du cours la 2de cependant
que vous n'avez pas assimiler et s'il y
avait 10 % les voitures qui sortait
d'une usine qui ne roulait pas ce sera
un vrai problème du gros quand on se
fait sortir des voitures d'une usine on
espère que le taux de voitures qui ne
roulent pas où est de l'ordre de 1 sur 1
million 1,1 sur sont donc donc leur
disait faudrait pas et viser d'avoir 18
sur 20 il faudrait viser comme note 20
facteurs de 1 mois dix puissance moins
six semaines donc
19 29 9 et 18 sont rares c'est dur il
vous reste des choses à comprendre il ya
encore des lacunes
il faut il faut ré les combler pour être
pourra vraiment avoir acquis à qui le
court et puis pour pouvoir passer au
tour suivant alors que vous pour
beaucoup 18 c'est vraiment une très
bonne note donc donc partir du principe
que notre rôle en tant qu'enseignant
sait transmettre des connaissances et
qu' il faut essayer de transmettre les
connaissances jusqu'à ce qu'elles soient
transmises et pas se contenter d'un
constat d'échec on déballe en étudiant à
7 et puis c'est pas grave et puis ou
bien il a pas l'examen bien il faut
autre chose
il passe quand même parce qu'il a
compensé avec un press qu'il avait
grandi d'autres dans une autre matière
cc c'est sans doute une manière de non
pas d'enseigné ça vraiment rien à voir
la manière dont ces bières une manière
de noter kiki qui devrait à terme être
est remplacée par une autre manière de
noter où on dit juste à l'étudiant voilà
ça c'est ça c'est compris ça c'est pas
comprise qui pas compris fois leur
travail et tu vas y arriver
c'est donc ça c'est sans doute une
manière qui de noter qu'ils amèneraient
- est-ce que des adultes garde un très
mauvais souvenir de leurs enseignements
de leur enseignement scientifique
voilà après il ya aussi des gars aussi
des gens qui ont des talents différents
pour différentes choses donc voila ce
mois ci je décide de courir le 100 m
aujourd'hui il est probable que même si
je m'entraîne beaucoup gérait pas aux
jeux olympiques donc probable que je les
sens répond en dessous de 10 secondes
mais bon c'est pas grave le henkin
henkin car des premières heures
travaillées sur le modèle de l'accord
est de type simple dont je parlais tout
à l'heure a fait s'est consacré la
deuxième moitié de sa carrière à
l'enseignement des mathématiques donc
est donc une histoire qui m'a été
racontée j'ai pas de référence donc
c'est un bobard que je vais vous
raconter une feuille close puisque je ne
peux pas les sources est précisément sa
mère elle se met à raconter par l'une de
ses étudiantes qui travaillent avec lui
donc il avait l'habitude de dire bon il
ya des gens qui sont bons en maths et
des gens qui sont mauvais en maths et
ceux qui sans brevet en maths on peut
les amener jusqu'au niveau master
donc après pour passer une thèse pour
avoir la médaille fields bon il faut
être bon en maths mais si on est mauvais
en maths on peut quand même aller
jusqu'au niveau master et aujourd'hui on
a l'idée que si on est mauvais en maths
on va jusqu'au haut niveau 5e c et c'est
insuffisant il faudrait ce que veut dire
que tout le monde peut aller jusqu'au
niveau 20 heures après les maquis c'est
meilleur que l'autre qui vont aller plus
loin c'est sympa c'est comme conduire
très clairement les gens sont très loin
de leur potentiel rabat et le
traumatisme des maths est vraiment
empreinte de dessin technique
oui oui oui donc dos voilà donc il ya
sans doute pas que ça et je suis sûr que
même si on il ya des gens et qui ont des
bonnes notes en maths et puis qui
ensuite se disent que les maths et
intéresse pas et qui sont pas clients de
la numérisation et c'est très bien il
faut il faut qu'ils en aient comme ça
mais je crois qu'ils en a beaucoup qui
ont cette espèce de traumatismes tu
décris très bien qu'on apprenne de santé
publique et que cela c'est un problème
qui ferait qu'on essaie de résoudre et
que ça c'est quelque chose qui
permettrait d'avoir une place des
sciences dans la société qui serait plus
saine
on aurait résolu un problème de santé
oms révèle situation que celle est
également ça serait plus sain pour la
société elle même que que les sciences
ne soit pas comme elles sont aujourd'hui
un peu marginalisé et qu'elles soient
plus largement plus largement partagée
j'ai envie d'arrêter de tes travaux de
dénégations sur les rives appelé entre
les deux mutations jusque là reçu le
grand prix de philosophie de l'académie
française
une métamorphose du camion est ce que tu
veux présenter un petit peu le livre
alors c'est un livre qui a une une
histoire très compliquée puisque au
départ mais l'as far outils qu'ils
étaient
mon éditrice au pommier à une certaine
époque avait voulu lancer une collection
de livres qui existent toujours qui
s'appelle 4 à 4 et qui qui présente les
l'ensemble des mathématiques on sait ce
volume et c'était 16 volumes qui étaient
publiés sur quatre ont donc avec 4 par
an et qui permettait de suivre un peu en
lisant les seize volumes dans un certain
ordre une progression et l'idée donner
là était une idée intéressante c'était
que souvent on a une progression dans un
livre de médiation mais une fois qu'on a
fermé la dernière page mais on attaque
un autre livre qui part sur des
progressions complètement différente et
bien souvent même ce qu'on n'arrive pas
à bien faire le lien entre ce qu'on lit
dans un livre est ce qu'on a lu le livre
précédent et que ça c'est une un biais
négatif de la delà de la médiation dans
savoir en général il ya des pièces de
puces qui doit s'imbriquer les unes dans
les autres
ça brille parfois imparfaitement tout
n'est pas toujours aussi car elles
seront en retrait mais bon au moins il
ya quand même une progression qui dure
sur au delà de 100 pages
une progression qui doit qui doit être
plus plus plus longues et donc l'idée
c'était de faire plusieurs livres qu'il
faut qu'ils doivent être enchaînés les
uns les uns aux autres et alors donc on
avait discuté avec n'est là avec benoît
rittaud avec d'autres gens de là la
progression à faire et j'avais proposé
que sur les seize lignes en est un qui
soit consacré à la notion de calcul et
ce qui m'intéressait c'était de
reprendre la notion de calcul en
mathématiques depuis l'origine des
mathématiques
donc depuis les mathématiques
babylonienne et s'est montré comment à
toutes les toutes les époques des
mathématiques à toutes les époques de
l'histoire des mathématiques
il y avait une espèce de de conflit ou
de détention des longues parce que c'est
pas nécessairement un conflit entre deux
manières de faire des mathématiques
qui sont une manière qui consiste à
faire des mathématiques en calculant et
une autre qui vont susciter par des
mathématiques en raisonnant et donc si
on reprend l'histoire des mathématiques
d'abord c'est le calcul qui est premier
puisque dans tout les mathématiques
sumérienne babylonienne en mésopotamie
et en egypte essentiellement des
algorithmes des méthodes de calcul dont
il ya des méthodes de calcul par les
éditions les multiplications et puis
avec les mathématiques grecque mais
notion de raisonnement apparaît mais on
fait souvent m la mathématique avec aux
grecs
parce que l'on considère que le
raisonnement est plus importante mais a
besoin de quelques et c'est celle vision
biaisée puisque le calcul existait avant
et puis en fait après l'aller mais
thématique médiévale revienne à une
notion de calcul puisque c'est le moment
où on découvre la numération imposition
dont il faut redécouvrir les algorithmes
pour la multiplication en particulier
avec la numéro 1 la numération
opposition qu'on pensait que avant on
avait des trucs qui ressemblait aux
chiffres romains et essaye de faire une
multiplication du titre rejoint tu
verras que c'est assez difficile et donc
là les mathématiques arabe
photo ap les mathématiques arabe puisque
la rame était la langue dominante de
mathématiques au moyen-âge détériore de
nouveau recentrer sur beaucoup sur des
questions d'algues aurait et que après
aux dents dans les mathématiques
modernes ont trouvé avec newton et les
mini le calcul différentiel qui était un
amoureux du calcul alors que les
méthodes anciennes mais les méthodes
grecque par exemple pour les ailes pour
déterminer des airs des volumes étaient
étaient des méthodes à la base du
raisonnement et puis après on a on
arrivait à
deux époques télé pas brûler
calculabilité avec tueries et l'époque
on a déjà parlé de la constructivité ou
à nouveau la notion de calcul
apparaissait d'une manière très caché
des manières créé créé détourné mais
mais mais était très présente et puis ça
et puis ça nous admet à l'époque
contemporaine ou où on avait donc des
démonstrations faites par des
ordinateurs vérifié par des ordinateurs
et surtout le fait que le fait d'avoir
des outils de calcul vous nous permettez
de faire des démonstrations qu'on aurait
jamais imaginé faire avant de la même
manière qu'à voir des microscopes nous a
permis de voir des des bactéries des
cellules étaient même l'intérieur de la
cellule d'une manière qui était
inaccessible à l'onu qui avait un effet
similaire avec les ordinateurs sur les
mathématiques qui était de nous
permettre de faire des démonstrations de
grande taille de traits calculatoire
qu'on n'aurait jamais pu qu'on n'aurait
jamais pu faire avant donc voila c'était
c'était le plan de mon livre et j'ai
commencé à l'écrire et puis bien entendu
comme tu as compris dans ce set
cette collection il fallait rendre le
livre à l'heure parce que c'était il ya
une progression
il y avait une politique de publication
qui levait sur et donc le j'ai pas du
tout réussi à rendre mon livre à l'heure
donc le jeu plus le plus j'écrivais et
plus que je croyais au début être un
petit livre d'une centaine de pages
encore se développer se développe et se
développe et gère avec lui je n'arrivais
plus à maîtriser ce processus
donc des lamas du bord laisse tomber
puis l'a fait sur le lit par quelqu'un
d'autre
et moi j'ai continué avec ce moment les
phoques est vraiment laid et puis du
coup j'ai quand même proposé donc à
cette maison d'édition alors bella et
est parti puis c'était sophie bancaires
qui avaient repris le le le le travail
éditorial que vous et que vous avez là
donc j'ai proposé à sofia et son fils
m'a dit mais ça c'est pas du tout un
livre de médiation ont classé le moment
où j'ai pas arrêté mais disons que j'ai
commencé à faire autre chose que la
médiation elle m'a dit mais c'est un
livre remettre dans la collection
philosophie des sciences
adjani mais je suis pas philosophe enfin
l'allemagne ne t'inquiète pas on va
mettre dans les collections philosophie
des sciences et puis du coup tu peu
moins de contraintes c'est à dire le la
contrainte que je m'étais imposé d'être
accessible à tous et c'est puisque
c'était à la médiation était de venir un
peu moins important pour qui c'était pas
une raison pour être ésotérique mais ils
ont je pouvais un peu plus maîtres des
formules vraiment désolant transgresser
tout un tas de lois que de la médiation
donc j'ai complètement réécrit bouquin
plus dans un style qui est est ce que
finalement ce vers quoi j'étais en train
en train de tendre et donc le bouquin a
été a été publié en 2007
et donc c'était la première fois que
j'écris un livre de philosophie
donc c'était au départ allait de
médiation qui était devenu un livre de
philosophie et du jour au lendemain je
me suis endormi reçoit lendemain matin
je me suis réveillé j'étais j'étais
philosophe parce que le livre a été
remarqué par l'académie française et
donc l'académie française remet chaque
année d un certain nombre de prix à un
certain nombre de livres est donc cette
année l'académie française avait avait
décidé de remettre le prix de
philosophie à ce livre est donc une fois
que j'ai reçus y prête une fille c'est
comme ça t'as pas même si tu ne sais pas
si qui ne sait pas faire une dissert sur
un risque de tout pathos à la fois
l'importance m'enfin bon je suis inquiet
de très particulier puisque ce qui
m'intéresse c'est le cd question de
philosophie des sciences et des
techniques principalement
et même si bon ces questions après bien
sûr elles interagissent avec d'autres
questions en philosophie et 10 ans qui
était ce qui avait intéressé les
académiciens en particulier michel
serres qui qui était celui qui avait
proposé le livre comme à ses collègues
et académicien
donc ça c'est ce que le président de
l'académie des françaises
le jour de la remise des prix il a
expliqué comment le livre avait été
proposé par michel serres ce que ce qui
est ce que ce que michel serres avait
avait dit c'était que la philosophie
telle qu'on la voyait était calquée sur
la le raisonnement c'est à dire que le
raisonnement philosophique sur 7 à la
même chose que le récent volet
thématique mais il a des accointances
avec le raisonnement mathématique et que
cette vision que des mathématiques
marcher sur deux pattes et pas qu'une
qui était d'un côté le raisonnement et
de l'autre côté le calcul nous poser un
vrai problème philosophique que personne
ni moi en fait ni personne n'avait
jamais vraiment à affronter qui était de
savoir est ce que il ya une bo sont
similaires à celles de calcul en
philosophie est ce qu'il ya des
problèmes philosophiques qui peuvent
être résolus par un calcul et non pas
par un raisonnement ou parle et donc ça
c'est ou alors est ce que au contraire
la la philosophie est délibérément
uniquement du côté de raisonnement et
contrairement aux mathématiques qui
serait à cheval sur le rat qui
fonctionnerait avec deux moteurs l'un
qui serait le raisonnement est notre lot
de calcul donc c'est celle c'est cette
question qui fait la bonne question de
plus de philosophie générale que de
philosophie des sciences que le livre
posé un peu en creux parce que moi
j'avais pas vraiment formulées sur la
question comme ça je mettais c'était
vraiment un livre de philosophie des
sciences pour que mme était plus
intéressé à la place duquel coule dans
les mathématiques et place du calcul
dans le dans le reste de la pensée ont
fait que c'est des choses qui m'ont
intéressé après mais par exemple si on
sera tout petit peu de philosophie il ya
une vraie question qui est est ce que le
droit est une théorie axiomatique ou est
ce que c'est un algorithme et si c'est
une théorie axiomatique ça pose tout un
tas de problèmes que d'une vision plus
algorithmique du droit résout
en particulier dans une théorie
axiomatique on pourrait imaginer qu'il
ya des problèmes qui sont insolubles
donc un théorème
c'est le pluralisme que les trames de
gödel qui nous dit dans toute théorie m
activa éthique et des problèmes
insolubles et donc ça ça nous amène à un
concept philosophique on appelle les
pôles kaki et la suspension du jugement
certes tu veux dire un moment je ne sais
pas sauf que quand tu juges
j'ai payé un voleur de pommes il ya
quelques années à quelqu'un dont on
accuse d'avoir volé des pommes et
l'autre qui qui dit c'est pas moi qui ai
volé l'épreuve c'est difficile de dire
projet de dire mais je ne sais pas je
suspends jugement le juge qui doit juger
en ce qui concerne les voleurs de pommes
évoluer assez vite et on ne peut pas non
plus prendre 30 ans pour réfléchir à ce
qu'est alors que si on imagine le droit
comme un processus plus algorithmique où
il n'ya pas attendez des axiaux qui nous
permet de construire des raisonnements
mais des règles qui vont permettre
d'aboutir à une conclusion à ce moment à
ce moment là on a une une
on a une vision du droit qui correspond
plus à ce qu'est le droit c'est à dire
au fait que le jugement on a un quart
d'heure pour une bière ou cinq heures
pour laurent 28 ans laurent et donc et
ça ça nous amène beaucoup à cette place
de l'époque et qui est vraiment le la
frontière on te calcule et le
raisonnement par exemple dans les dents
dans le lin génériques dont le génie
c'est à dire quand on fabrique un pont
le but c'est qu'à la fin il ya un pont
c'est pas qu'on ait dit on sait pas
comment faire le pont si on dire on ne
sait pas s'il est possible de faire le
pont sait pas comment faire le pont ne
pas un bon ingénieur
le bonheur n'est pas celui qui qui
démontre qu'il est impossible de faire
un pont c'est celui qui
[Musique]
qui fait le pont est donc là aussi qui
fait le pont pas en sentant qu'il
fallait pendant trois ans quatre ans
donc donc là aussi il ya une dans la
dans l'action et dans la construction
dans la technique il n'y a pas cette
possibilité de suspension du jugement
et ça fait que l'activité technique
peut-être se rapproche plus d'une notion
de deux calculent que d'une motion que
que une leçon de raisonnement voilà donc
ça c'est d'aider réflexion que j'ai
menée ensuite mais dijon c'était pour
moi plus une bascule parce que après
j'ai écrit d'autres livres comme par
exemple le dernier livre que j'ai que
j'ai écrits qui s'appelle ce dont on
peut parler il faut l'écrire qu'ils
soient de son langage autant les
métamorphoses du calcul était alors
c'est ça à voile avec cécilia ciganer ce
film de woody allen ou olivier est ce
que c est ce que c'est un hommage je
sais plus quel hacker le cinéaste est
énorme et juste piqué l'idée donc je ne
sais pas a sauvé la vie d'une style je
vais juste appliqué des deux jeunes
impliqués de titres et donc le le dans
ce livre là aussi je me suis un peu
placé sur le même sur le même le même
mode qui était celui de faire un livre
de philosophie les sciences et pas
nécessairement un livre de médiation
même s'ils pensent qu'ils accessible à
beaucoup de gens enfin il n'y a pas deux
principales et vraies difficultés de
l'unir mais disons le jeu je n'hésite
pas à développer des aspects un peu plus
un peu plus philosophique de ce que
j'avais fait dans les dents dans mes
premiers textes et donc c'est en fait à
ce moment là au moment où j'ai écrit les
métamorphoses du calcul que j'ai
commencé un peu cette seconde carrière
de philosophe des sciences puisque
puisque deux médiateurs qui continue à
faire de la médiation
mais moi écrire les médiations
maintenant aujourd'hui quand on fait de
la médiation jeu c'est plus par exemple
en allant faire une conférence dans un
lycée ou en allant
faire une conférence dans un musée je
suis devrait finalement avec l'otan plus
à un médiateur orale et en écrivant plus
des choses qui ressemblent à de la
décence que la médiation
bien avant cette histoire de jugement de
calcul j'ai découvert récemment que le
en rade c'est le même mot jugement et
calcul oui oui oui effectivement là il
ya il ya une il y avait martine 9 avait
fait cette remarque il avait fait un
exposé sur l'origine de la notion de
jugement dans la théorie de martine
loock dans la logique de martin 9 il ya
une notion propositions il me son
jugement qui sont assez différentes que
des notions qu'il a repris à quand une
distinction qu'il a repris un acompte
qui est d'ailleurs une distinction assez
controversé pas mal de gens qui disent
qu'il n'y a pas besoin de cette
distinction d'eau qui disent qu'elle est
au coeur de la théorie de la
connaissance et donc martin avait fait
une conférence une fois sur l'origine de
la notion de jugement toujours bien
cette notion de jugement et donc il
avait il avait insisté sur le fait que
que en arabe
les baux sont pas découpées par ailleurs
je me souviens plus exactement ce qui si
le jugement était le mot lui-même au
calcul mais rageur je me souviens que et
en particulier il y a le mot jugement
est un mot qui vient du langage
juridique avant de venir du langage
philosophique et il ya une question sur
le s que le sans doute excessif de dire
ça dans ces termes mais est ce que la
notion de vérité n'est pas d'abord une
notion juridique avant d'être une notion
philosophique
alors c'est sans doute excessif de dire
ça mais on a sans doute beaucoup
sous-estimé dans toute la pensée
philosophique sur la notion de vérité
on a sans doute sous-estimé l'importance
l'apport du droit et en particulier avec
cette notion de jugement alors après il
ya eu d'autres jeux de mots plutôt le
cap et ce à des jeux de mots dison b
des considérations étymologique en
anglais ou par exemple la proposition
sony centers
donc c'est la sentence est donc on voi
que les mots jugement sentence était
encore ont quand même un à un à l'air
d'avoir un point commun une proximité
avec avec le vocabulaire juridique et la
pensée juridique est donc cette question
de l'origine juridique de la vérité qui
nous amènerait d'ailleurs enfin disons
delà de la part du droit dans la
définition qu'on a aujourd'hui de la
vérité nous nous ça va être beaucoup à
relativiser l'importance de la delà du
raisonnement puisque le droit c'est
d'abord des procédures des procédures
juridiques avant d'être une philosophie
du droit le droit ça se rend d'abord et
ensuite ça peut on peut avoir une
réflexion philosophique en amont mais le
réflexion philosophique sur le droit qui
ne mènerait pas à rendre un jugement à
la fin elle jugeait à à une personne
coupable ou innocente n'aurait pas une
véritable efficacité en droit donc
donc quand on voit cette proximité du
droit et de la de la fin de cette
origine juridique de la notion de vérité
ça nous amène vraiment à penser
différemment les rapports entre
raisonnement il calcule en droit et en
philosophie et en dans la technique est
pas l épanouissement des sciences
restent retraçant elle crée aussi pas
mal sur la thèse de torture inc oui donc
ça c'était 1-1
un petit morceau de la métamorphose du
calcul
j'avais écrit un chapitre sur la sur la
calculabilité donc je t'avais dit
j'avais un petit peu retracer toute
l'histoire de la notion de calcul dans
les bains dans les mathématiques alors
bien sûr en approfondissant a beaucoup
chèque chaque époque
mais je m'étais un peu plus appesanti
sur le xxème siècle et en particulier
donc il ya une partie du livre qui est
qui est consacrée à la l'histoire de la
de la calculabilité et il y avait cette
époque une j'essaie de réfléchir à des
des liens qu'il y avait entre donc la
thèse de turc du ring qui est d'ailleurs
celui qui s'appelle encore la thèse de
chuck c'est marrant parce que le mot a
évolué mais j'avais l'impression que
l'évolution des plus anciennes maisons
puisque j'emploie le mot test de church
dans ce dans ce livre qu'en 2007 et
d'autres d'autres libé en particulier en
physique j'ai glissé dans la rue mais
alors voilà donc il faut il faut google
que j'explique un tout petit peu d'où
vient ce nom donc church c'est le nom de
famille d'une personne qui m'est pas
dont les liens avec l'église sur sa
route
ancien puisque on ne connaît pas comme
étant des religieux n'est ni religieux
ni rien par contre ces idées religieuses
n'ont pas l'air d'avoir une grande
importance dans sa vie enfin en tout cas
d'antan dans son oeuvre et auxerre tient
à un des logiciens des années 30
donc de ce qu'on appelle parfois l'âge
d'or de la logique donc c'est un
contemporain de gödel donc on a parlé
tout à l'heure mais un petit turing dont
on a parlé donc c'est à peu près la même
génération et il se situe exactement
entre lionel et turing c'est à dire il
ay là il a reçu l'influencent de guidel
et donc il est beau il est très marqué
par l'essentiel de sa de sa de ces
contributions sont dans les années 30 et
et apparemment les il avait il était un
des rares à avoir compris l'importance
des travaux de grenelle a dès le début
des années 2000 un écran et avoir essayé
de les poursuivre
et puis c'est plus ou moins lors des
directeurs de test de turing puisque
turing encore étudiant donc trinitain
royaume uni et pictures qui était aux
états unis et donc turing a fait un
voyage pour aller voir church et essayer
de comprendre cette idée de d'échanger
ses idées mes tee shirts étaient déjà
ceintures ring était étudiante cherche
était déjà un vieux prof et donc il ya
il ya une quasiment une relation de
peinture il est quasiment disciple de
church même si c'était pas son sang sont
vrais profs sont rapprochés newman qui
était un prof au royaume uni à cambridge
je ne sais plus enfin bref au royaume
uni peu importe
et donc à cette époque c'est une époque
intéressante où on a déjà une réflexion
très avancés sur les notions de calcul
et sur ce qu'il est possible de calculer
ce que l'état possible de calculer alors
que l'invention des ordinateurs et pour
la décennie suivante la ressent des
ordinateurs sela décédée 1940 et là on
est dans l'année dans la décennie 1930
et à une époque où y'a pas encore
l'ordinateur tshirt et turing
indépendamment et c'est pour ça qu'on
appelle ça aujourd'hui la thèse de
torture in propose une idée selon
laquelle les langages dans lesquels on
exprime les algorithmes ses relais les
les
la notion d'algorithmes dont on dispose
à l'époque et notion indépassable donc
qu'est-ce que ça veut dire ça veut dire
dans l'eure dans leur manière de penser
il faut comprendre qu'il n'est pas
l'ordinateur sinon on peut pas
comprendre ce qu'ils racontent ils
disent à chaque fois qu'on va plus tard
découvrir un nouvel algorithme dans dans
la suite de l'histoire des mathématiques
et bien on saura qu'il qu'il pouvait
s'exprimer dans le cadre qu'on donne
aujourd'hui des définitions condamne la
notion d'algorithmes et il y avait deux
notions à cette époque une qui était dû
à church road qui était dû à turing est
ce qu'il leur a donné
cette fois entre guillemets dans la
solidité de la relation
c'est que même si church et turing était
parti sur les idées très différentes
alors church est l'inventeur d'un
langage le lombez calcul et turing des
machines de tueries mais bon peu importe
les chaînes youtube ne s'est pas des
machines c'est important savoir qui
n'est pas devenue encore à cette époque
comme chez nokia xpress pas des
ordinateurs mais avec ces deux manières
d'exprimer les algorithmes church et
urine s'aperçoivent qu'ils apprise
arrive avec prime exactement les même
algorithmes
c'est à dire tout ce que picture je
pouvais faire dans ce langage curieux
pouvaient le faire dans le sien et vice
versa et donc on est ça me ramène un peu
au début de notre entretien
on est vraiment dans cette idée de
traduction d'un langage vers un autre on
s'aperçoit qu'elle engage sont
absolument identiques qu'ils extraient
exactement les mêmes choses et ça ça
leur donne une espèce de 2,2 fois dans
leur langage en disant puisque on est
tombé sur le même résultat
indépendamment c'est que c'est cet
ensemble d'algorithmes ces langages de
description d'algorithmes ont un
caractère absolu est donc un caractère
absolu c'est alors qu'on n'arrivera
jamais à l'aiea les dépasser alors ça
peut paraître un peu bizarre comme
manière de penser et de se dire qu'est
ce qui va se passer dans le futur mais
on pourrait dire que les nombres concon
les nombreux sentiers enfin eric
aujourd'hui avec 0,1 et l'addition donc
3 parlant c'est un plus en prison là il
n'est pas totalement absurde que de dire
que tous les nombres qu'on va considérer
dans le futur il ya tous les nombreux
chantiers qu'on va voir le futur on peut
les obtenir à partir de zéro ans et plus
et c'est quelque chose qui n'est pas une
ils sont pas lui dans le marc de café
c'est vraiment une
une thèse qui est presque scientifique à
l'est pas et scientifique de fait mais
elle est presque scientifique et après
les ordinateurs arrive et cette thèse de
sortie du ring change de nature
à tel point qu'on lui donne un autre nom
l'appel forme physique de la tête de
turc du riz et elle devient beaucoup
plus simple à comprendre
elle consiste à dire si on invente
n'importe quelle machine demain eh bien
elle ne permettra pas le calcul est
davantage des algorithmes que les
machines qu'on a aujourd'hui
ça c'est quelque chose d'un qui assez
déprimant pour un certain nombre de
joueurs par tuer les gens qui fabrique
des ordinateurs ils savent qu'ils
pressent des ordinateurs qui vont plus
vite ils font peut faire des ordinateurs
qui sont plus beaux chants un plus grand
écran qui ont plus de tout sur le
clavier mais ne pourront pas faire des
ordinateurs qui a intrinsèquement
calculeront plus de choses et c'est
cette idée elle a été reprise par un
étudiant de turing qui s'appelle gambie
est bon dit il faut essayer de démontrer
que c'est vrai ça il faut essayer de
démontrer qu'un ordinateur ne peut pas
calculer plus que ce que calculer les
machine de turing les les les termes du
nombre des calculs de church est
désormais les premiers ordinateurs qu'on
a sous les yeux donc tout d'un coup le
problème devient devient beaucoup plus
concret et à ce moment là ça pose la
question qu'est ce qu'un ordinateur qui
est qu'est ce qu'on peut appeler une
machine qu'est ce qui nous si on n'a pas
une définition un peu précise de ce
qu'est une machine bon on peut toujours
dire un jour en avoir une machine qui
fera d'eux des choses merveilleuses mais
est-ce qu'on peut limiter notion des
limites et nos 100 machines qui nous
permette de de donner un sens à cette
thèse est donc gondi invente trois
principes
oui d'abord une machine certains
systèmes physiques donc comme tous les
systèmes physiques ça doit vérifier une
propriété d'un variance dans le temps et
dans l'espace mais dit aussi et là on
voit qu'il ya eu une influence de la
physique du xxème siècle qui est très
très très fort
il dit aussi d'autres dans une machine
et on peut pas transmettre de
l'information plus vite que la vitesse
de la lumière et et ça on s'aperçoit que
dès qu'on laisse tomber cette contrainte
c'est très facile d'imaginer machine qui
calcule beaucoup plus vite beaucoup plus
de fonctions beaucoup plus d'algorithmes
que les machine de turing version si on
s'autorise à une transmission
instantanée d'information qui rend gêne
on pense que c'est pas possible dans la
nature enfin si on s'autorise à ce
moment là on peut faire des machines qui
qui dépasse la barrière de turing donc
il faut effectivement au couple et à
grandir a eu un brin trop nul une idée
très nouvelle était de dire également là
l'information peut pas stocker une
quantité infinie d'information dans un
volume fini et est donc ça c'est quelque
chose qui n'était pas du tout apparu
dans la physique avant autant la vitesse
de transmission de l'information il ya
mais la relativité et c est donc donc
c'était une idée qui était tout à fait
banale presque à l'époque de gandhi mais
pas du tout là c'est cette idée d'une
densité fifine et l'information et il
vendit d'ailleurs ne propose pas ça
comme un principe de physique
ils ont dit appelons une machine quelque
chose qui vérifie ce système physique
qui vérifie ce principe et puis il ya
peut-être d'autres systèmes physiques
qu'ils vérifient pas et ai grandi montre
que à ce moment là avec n'importe quel
physique avec n'importe quel système
physique on peut pas calculer davantage
que ce qu'on faisait avec avec les
machine de turing les terres du temps de
calcul les ordinateurs qu'on a
aujourd'hui et c est au même moment il
ya un physicien qui s'appelle jacob
bekenstein donc ça on est dès maintenant
dans les années 60 mais la fin des
années 60 qui dînait en fait dans
l'univers il y à une borne qu'on appelle
l'ère de ben stein et on peut pas on
peut pas stocker plus d'informations on
peut pas stocker on peut pas avoir une
densité d'information qui va au delà au
nahd cette borne et leur tout d'un coup
on met toutes ses idées boutabout on
s'aperçoit qu'on est très loin des
considérations de clôture initiale qui
était vraiment sur d'élus langage
d'expression d'agora
on se disait alors tous les systèmes
physiques ne peuvent rien calculer de
plus que le que ce que fait une machine
de turing
et on peut dire d'un certain point de
vue une manière de dire ça c'est que
tous les phénomènes physiques peuvent
être simulé c'est à dire si on prend
n'importe quel un système physique
jusqu'à une pierre qui tombe un atom qui
est qui se désintègre s'apprêtant
systèmes physiques déterministe non
déterministe et c est bien tout ce qu'on
peut tout ce que la nature peut faire on
peut le simuler avec avec un ordinateur
et donc ça on s'aperçoit et que du coup
on est très loin de l'ordinateur comme
objet technique qui nous permet de de de
prédire ce qu'il va faire un système
physique
on est vraiment dans l'ordinateur qui
est où le langage dans lequel on exprime
les programmes de stimulation qui sont
devenus à langage universel pour décrire
le monde et donc ça c'est une
transformation qui s'est fait donc entre
les années 30 et les années 70 on est
passé de l'idée d'exprimer des
algorithmes comme l'alluré de l'édition
et la multiplication des algorithmes and
plutôt simple nous allons être plus
compliqué comme calculer des taux
d'intérêts composés ou à à l'idée que
les langages de programmation était des
langages qui permettent de décrire le
bon et donc j'avais j'avais que j'avais
essayé de l'expliquer sadran dans un
chapitre des métamorphoses du calcul et
en particulier sur le fait que ça
rejoignait une question qui est une
question irrésolue qui était pourquoi
est ce que le monde peut se décrire dans
un langage mathématique est donc là
c'est une très vieille question que
wickmayer avait posé comme the times
avait posé mais qu'en fait remonte
vraisemblablement à galilée ont gagné le
premier à proposer que langage
mathématique soit un bon langage pour
décrire le monde mais sans jamais dire
pourquoi et donc est donc là on avait
une espèce d'explication de la thèse de
galilée libé que le monde puisse décrire
dans un langage mathématique si on le
souhaite qu'ils étaient liés à cette à
cette thèse de chercher du ring dans sa
forme physique démontré par gandhi avec
l'apport de beketch tide et c est donc
c'est c'est une idée qui bon que quand
j'ai écrit ce chapitre ce procès c'est
toujours intéressant de savoir quel
était l'état d'esprit dans lequel on
était qu'on avait quand même qu'on a
écrit un livre mais il m'était apparu en
l'écrivant que peut-être c'était ce
chapitre la queue on allait retenir du
livre et des retouches à vue j'avais
vaguement eu cette intuition mais pas au
point de dire je laisse tomber le livre
et puis j'ai écrit un livre uniquement
sur ce sujet mais bon je m'étais dit
peut-être dans la perception que les
lecteurs vont avoir dû vivre alors
c'était pas du tout les que l'électeur
philosophe en retenue et en revanche ça
a été ce que beaucoup de lecteurs ont
retenu dans le bon sens que c'est c'est
une thèse qui a c'est assez difficile en
fait à admettre qui est que finalement
le monde n'est pas si compliqué que ça
puisque on peut pas faire un monde très
compliqué dans lequel l'information se
propage à une vitesse fini et
l'information a une densité fini densité
bornes et une vitesse bornet si c'est le
cas c'est dire comment n'est pas si
compliqué et c'est peut-être parce que
le monde n'est pas si compliqué qui peut
se décrire dans un langage
alors ça c'est c'est une thèse qui est
un peu iconoclaste puisque jugé que le
monde est simple est souvent considéré
comme une vision un peu simpliste
alors j'ai beau dire qu'on peut mettre
10 puis 170 bits pour un mètre carré
donc 10 870 c'est quand même beaucoup en
chine 70 0 donc si vous le diront
milliards de milliards de milliards il
faut il faut dire le bauhb il ya sept ou
huit fois mais donc
donc il ya une vraie complexité mais met
cependant cette complexité n'est pas
infinie le cdh une certaine forme
il ya eu au moment de gagner les idées
qu'on était passé d'un monde fini à un
monde infini avec l égalité avec le
leader l'espace infini alors que le
monde à montréal ils étaient enfermés
dans des orbes enfin on était vraiment
dans un monde fini et on s'aperçoit ici
que comme d'ailleurs c'est arrivé à
d'autres d'autres endroits en cosmologie
quoique tout l'alcool on en revient à
l'idée d'un monde fini mais les ondes en
bas d'un monde qui a une part de
finitude et ça c'est une idée qui heurte
beaucoup et qui a heurté beaucoup de
lecteurs qui avec lesquels je me suis
intéressé un autre controverse et elle a
dit à discuter de ces idées et je
sentais toujours chez nous de réticences
qui était dirai pas de nature religieuse
ce serait ça serait pas gentil pour mais
détendue une espèce de réticences
absolue qui était de dire qu'il était
c'était pas bien de dire que le monde
était simple c'est que t'es pas bien de
dire le monde était finie c'était pas
bien de dire que on n'avait pas rester
que l'on n'était pas ce puits sans fond
maintenant regardez c'est un puits très
profond mais un manteau qui en font et
ça c'est ça c'est une ville très
dérangeante cessé puisque le fait que ce
soit si minable par dans les terres
parce que c'est plus le fait que ce soit
alors il ya aussi le côté de l'idée que
ce soit stimulée par un ordinateur même
si c'est si minable par un ordinateur en
théorie puisque
si on veut simuler le monde avec un
ordinateur il faut que l'ordinateur soit
aussi beau que le monde donc un
ordinateur aussi beau que le monde il
peut pas être dans le monde donc dans la
terreur du monde donc c'est donc quand
on dit ça peut être ciblés par un
ordinateur c'est bien sûr une image mais
cependant il y avait aussi un changement
un peu de ce statut delà de
l'informatique ou pour un certain nombre
de chercheurs de ma génération ou disons
d des générations antérieures
l'ordinateur est un outil pratique dont
c'était une espèce de règle à calcul
améliorée mais une personne s'estimant
il a calculé peint par b mais tout d'un
coup on disait dans mais regardez on
peut cibler le monde entier avec un
ordinateur et donc elle est aussi une
idée du bri de des informaticiens qui
tout d'un coup ce 10ème on est capable
de simuler le monde entier sur un
ordinateur
donc il y avait aussi cette idée qui
était qui était dérangeant je pense que
les deux était dérangeante mais dans un
cas comme dans l'autre je pense qu'il
faut vraiment levé les relativiser en
disant certes le monde et simula par
l'ordinateur via un ordinateur au
cerveau que le monde et donc c'est pas
avec le pc qu'on a sur sa table qu'on va
qu'on va simuler l'univers et même si on
peut l'assimiler pas mal de trucs et la
même manière quand on dit il ya une le
monde est en fête et pixellisée il est
pas il n'est pas divisible à l'infini et
donc on retrouve un peu les idées
atomiste ici ou des idées
pythagoricienne est bon mais il et
pixellisée quand même avec des pixels
qui font à 10 puissance moins soixante
dix mètres carrés donc c'est quand même
très très très petit sait pas quand on
est pas on n'est pas loin du compte et
du malgré-tout oui ça fonctionne assez
petit qu'on n'arrive même pas à penser
c'est incroyable de penser des gros si
petit il ya un côté simple mais si on
compte vraiment des grandes mon père
mais ça fait des grands mais du coup on
peut mesurer sa complicité ont aidé à
défaut de dire que l'univers une
complexité infinie
on s'aperçoit qu'elle très grande
complexité mais que cette complicité et
exprimable dans un mémorable dans un
langage voit à quel point tu penses que
la thèse des quartiers bas mon opinion
n'a aucune importance
non ce qui m'intéresse ce qui
m'intéresse c'est pas d'être un gourou
et il ya des gourous dans les deux camps
donc il ya des gourous qui te disent que
la tête de turc et absolument certaine
d'autres qui te disent que la thèse de
tshirts bien sûr totalement incroyable
impossible à croire
voilà donc ça ça n'a pas de sens de se
placer sur le plan de l'opinion ce qui
est intéressant c'est d'essayer de voir
que il ya des liens entre des idées qui
sont finalement assez disparates qui a
un lien entre la thèse de church du ring
et la thèse de ganivelles et donc j'ai
souvent dit que la thèse petite chance
inouïe impliqua thèses de galilée mais
que si on les met pas cette formulation
pouvait dire que la négation la thèse de
galilée impliqué la négation la tête de
torsion et donc quand on quand on quand
on dit en mathématiques un pitbull on ne
dit pas que yves besson on dit que s'il
y avait eu alors ben ouais donc donc qui
avait d'abord un lien entre la thèse de
surf uriner la thèse de galilée mais
également un lien entre
gandhi et bekenstein donc avec cette
même île est une densité bornem de
l'information et que oui alors voilà
donc le l'autre côté un peu dérangeant
dans cette histoire c'est que qu'est-ce
que les caisses qui atteint la borne de
de la densité de l'information c'est les
trous noirs
donc on se dit voilà le meilleur moyen
de stocker de l'information c'est
d'utiliser un trou noir
et voilà donc que tout d'un coup on est
en étant on était parti sur la ligne
rennes de l'édition en train de parler
des trous noirs et est donc le plus que
plus plus que des volets d' essayer de
dire quand est ce que le principe
d'inertie est vrai ou faux on n'en sait
rien à ce qui nous intéresse c'est à
dire que si le principe d'inertie est
vrai alors on à ses conséquences est une
autre question c'est de savoir est ce
que le principe d'inertie est réfutable
c'est à dire est ce qu'on peut faire une
expérience qui mettra en défaut cette
hypothèse est une question qui est est
ce que on peut mettre en défaut le
principe de bekenstein qu'est ce que est
ce qu'on peut est ce que c est ce que
c'est une thèse réellement scientifique
c'est à dire au sens où est-ce qu'elle
est falsifiable est-ce qu'on peut la
mettre en défaut et la réponse est oui
mais bien sûr l'expérience qui la
mettrait en défaut une expérience de
pensée puisqu'il suffirait de prendre un
dé à coudre de mettre plus que 10
puissance 70 dedans et de les ressortir
et de vérifier que c'était la même chose
voilà on y est on a réfuté l'hypothèse
de mécanismes donc donc bien sûr on est
très loin d'une expérience qu'on peut
vraiment faire avec un télescope pour un
microscope ou un accélérateur de
particules mais en théorie on s'aperçoit
qu'il est possible d'imaginer des
expériences il marais contredire
l'hypothèse de bacon stein donc
c'est ça les questions qui sont
intéressants parce que ces hypothèses
scientifiques laquelle implique laquelle
est ce qu'on est purement dans des
spéculations est ce qu'on peut se
rattacher à quelque chose devant
pierrick c'est ça qui est ça les
questions intéressantes
après les questions d'opinions bas ça il
faut il faut demander au café du
commerce qui fait du commerce lors
devant avec le point d'éclater sur ses
origines resteras les autres s'en
charger
ça n'a pas d'intérêt ce qui est vraiment
intéressant s'il comprend qu'ils aient
vraiment de l'intérêt à mes yeux en tout
cas cessé de comprendre quelle est la
structure des arguments que comment est
ce que les arguments s'imbriquent les
uns avec les autres et surtout comment
est-ce que les arguments qui viennent
alors pour le coup des trous noirs du
lambert calcul etc
tout d'un coup fonctionnent ensemble
elles font font font théorie quoi et
donc là après à nouveau dit avec car un
certain nombre de deux de nos collègues
à moisdon non pas vouloir y ait ou
d'autres ont dit voilà on est en train
de trouver un nouveau cadre scientifique
avec des des nouveaux objets des
nouveaux paradigmes qui sont des
nouvelles questions qui sont échec
qu'est-ce qui peut simuler quoi etc et
donc on est qui est un domaine
scientifique qui est à la fois un
morceau d'informatique un morceau de la
physique un morceau démarre donc et ça
c'est intéressant parce qu'il ya une
petite révolution scientifique
après il faut aussi être raisonnable sur
le fait que jusqu'à aujourd'hui 99% les
physiciens s'intéresse pas à cette
question que mais que de celles lui même
et son copain routing peine rosemont
était séné physicien très particulier
des noms qui est qu' on va pas demain
faire ni les nouvelles voitures des
nouveaux ordinateurs fondée sur ses
idées
donc tant que ça reste quand même une
révolution scientifique dans un milieu
un peu confiné de la physique théorique
de l'informatique théorique et terra
d'oc
c'est pas une révolution scientifique
qui va changer complètement la manière
dont on fait de la science mais bon
cependant c'est une révolution
scientifique qui mérite d'être
d'être notée d'être embarqué disque dur
avec 10 kg 70
écoute moi j'attends aussi si la thèse
de michael steiner faut c'est qu'on peut
mettre plus que déçu 170 buts je m'en
réjouir jour je pourrai balader avec un
petit disque fera une quantité infinie
d'information si notre merveilleux
peut-être casser le lien cheering
el-ghany des jeux comme ça parce que
c'est facile sortir un livre à fond du
milliard et 6,9 mais avec un code qui
oui bien sûr alors il ya une question
qui était un peu annexes dans cette
danse et dans ce questionnement sur la
raison pour laquelle le monde et
mathématisée nous disons le monde
peut-être décrit dans dans dans un
langage mathématique et jaya mieux cette
formulation enfin les deux veulent dire
la même chose a bien entendu mais quand
on dit le monde est mathématique on fait
porter la la propriété mathématiques au
monde alors qu'en fait ce qu'on se
construit c'est que le monde peut être
décrite dans un langage mathématique
c'est déjà beaucoup qu'ils puissent
l'être mais nokia mais une autre
question qui avait été posé qui était
mais pourquoi est ce que les équations
sont si simples
et effectivement il se peut que le monde
soit mathématisée qu'on puisse le
décrire en langage mathématique mais il
se pourrait que au lieu d'avoir quatre
équations comme les équations de maxwell
ou trois équations que l'adéquation de
newton on ait besoin de 1 milliard 700
cette ambition d'équations alors à ce
moment là ça serait moins utiles en
pratique en tout cas et donc ça c'est
une question à laquelle on n'a pas
vraiment de réponse alors il ya une
réponse qui est un peu une réponse un
peu facile de dire finalement il ya des
phénomènes physiques qui sont
extrêmement difficile à décrire puis
d'autres qui sont faciles à décrire et
les
et scientifique choisissent les
phénomènes facile à décrire donc il y
avait déjà une explication qui était de
dire que le monde était mais thématise à
parce que les scientifiques et
choisissait les phénomènes mathématisée
dans le monde ou alors ça maintenant
c'est plus ou moins une explication que
j'essaye d'écarter mais en revanche
pourquoi est ce que les phénomènes
physiques se laisse décrire par les
équations simple là du coup il me semble
que l'argument selon lequel il ya des
phénomènes simple et des phénomènes
complexes et on aime bien les phénomènes
simple on ignore un peu les phénomènes
complexes et en est un argument qui est
un tout qui veut plus de portée et à 1
un physicien qui dit ça avait dû d'une
manière un peu un papa pas exactement ça
mais une idée qui as est assez proche
c'est david deutsch qui pose les
questions il dit là la révolution
galiléennes elle vient du fait que on
s'est aperçu que les planètes se déplace
sur le sur le sur la voûte céleste
donc autant les positions relatives des
étoiles sur la voûte céleste est à peu
près constante autant les planète bouge
parce qu'elles sont beaucoup plus
proches de nous et elle tourne autour du
soleil donc on les voit bouger et donc
tout toute la théorie des orbes et après
tout la tout tout tout tout le lieu
centrisme est venue de cette idée qu'il
fallait expliquer le mouvement des
planètes
et il y met en fait des planètes on n'en
voit pas beaucoup on voit
mercure un peu pas beaucoup envoient
vénus mars jupiter et saturne et ses
tours uranus des plus on les voit pas
enfin les lieux en tout cas et donc
pourquoi ce pourquoi se focaliser sur
ses cinq petits points qui bouge dans
ciel alors qu'il ya d'autres objets qui
bouge qui sont beaucoup plus gros
boutons beaucoup plus intéressante et
les nuages
pourquoi est-ce que galilée s'est
intéressée ou avant lui les les les
savants du moyen-âge qui ont conçu la
théorie des orbes d'antiquités de ménage
me souviens plus très bien l'histoire de
cette théorie pourrait ce qu'ils sont
concentrés sur ces points là et pas sur
les nuages alors là une explication
possible c'est de dire que finalement a
posteriori on s'aperçut que décrire le
mouvement des planètes étaient pas si
compliqué bon il a fallu attendre kepler
pour qu'on sache performant malgré tout
il y à des destructions possible du
mouvement des planètes
alors que les nuages le mouvement des
nuages pour le coup ça c'est un mot
voire extrêmement complexe à mettre en
équation c'est un mouvement et qui est
chaotique enfin hockey et est donc une
réponse qu'on pourrait faire à deutsch
même si il ya quelques anachronismes
dans cette
dans cette réponse c'est de dire qu'on
s'est intéressé au mouvement des
planètes parce que le wade planète a
l'air d'être une certaine régularité a
l'air d'être aussi la décrire dans le
dans un langage mathématique avec peu
d'équations alors qu'on sait que par
était de chuck turing le mouvement des
nuages peut-être des crimes mais si le
code du programme où le ou la taille des
équations et supérieur la taille d'une
image c'est pas très intéressant et donc
du coup on a moins regardés on a moins
cherché à prédire la forme des nuages le
mouvement des nuages d'une manière du
d'une manière très précise et donc on
peut dire qu'il ya quand même beaucoup
de phénomènes qui nous échappe non pas
parce qu'ils sont pas prédictible ou pas
ils font ils sont pas calculés loup ou
quand ils sont dans déterministe on
pourrait pas calculer leur probabilité
mais parce que ces calculs sont
tellement complexes qu'on n'est pas
capable de les faire est un exemple de
sacchi en exemple callable intéressant
parce qu'il est juste à la frontière de
ça c'est l'europe le repliement des
protéines
voilà on sait que le repliement des
protéines obéit à des lois etc
on sait qu'on peut le stimulait bon
c'est qu'il est extrêmement difficile a
été ciblé que le meilleur moyen de
simuler c'est d'observer la manière dont
la protéine se replie sur la protéine
est elle même un petit ordinateur qui
simule le mouvement de la protéine ce
qui est normal puisque c'est elle même
donc elle se simuler le même et c'est ça
c'est facile
donc on se dit que peut-être il ya des
phénomènes qui sont un peu plus
complexes que le repliement des
protéines qu'on arrivera le parc sans
doute jamais à simuler ce qui n'empêche
pas qu'il soit si minable en théorie
mais en pratique on n'a jamais le
simulait puisque le la simulation serait
beaucoup plus complexe que l'objet
lui-même et donc l europe à dentaires
sont une question est ce que la
mécanique quantique
on est encore en question alors non
c'est un nom qui n'est pas totalement
catégorique au sens où il ya la forme
est identique nous permet de faire des
ordinateurs au fameux permettrait de
faire des ordinateurs qui calculerait
plus vite mais pas forcément mais non
mais pas plus de fonctions donc donc
s'armer pas là là là
en cause la thèse de torture it est
telle qu'elle est définie après il y à
un certain nombre de gens qui
considèrent vitesse plus forte que la
tête de turc du ring en faisant entrer
mais qu'on dise des considérations de
complexité dans la tête de turc du ring
et à ce moment là il ya des classes de
complexité qui sont cassées par les
ordinateurs quantiques c'est à dire des
des choses qu'on il ya des algues aurait
par exemple trouver une aiguille dans
une botte de foin en calculs classiques
c'est-à-dire sans utiliser la mécanique
quantique ça demande un tank et propres
tiennent à taille de la botte de foin
parce qu'il faut chercher des morceaux
de foie par cette fois ci on à
l'aiguillé ou non alors qu'il ya un
algorithme qui valait de groover qui sur
un ordinateur quantique permet de
retrouver une donnée dans une base de
données qui a un élément en a tant qui
racines de haine donc c'est quelque
chose d'assez contre-intuitif parce
qu'on a l'impression qu'il faut quand
même regarder l'un après l'autre tous
les tous les éléments d'un 22 mai mais
l'alluré de groover permet de regarder
différents éléments de la base de
données en même temps avec un seul
ordinateur
donc ça c'est l'un des grands résultat
du calcul quantique alors cependant il
ya un certain nombre de chercheurs qui
essayent de pousser le calcul quantique
un peu au delà de ce qu'on sait
aujourd'hui et qui de ce qu'on conçoit
aujourd'hui en tout cas et qui disent qu
il serait possible de passer la barrière
de turing avec un ordinateur quantique
c'est d'être à vocation très controversé
qui mais qui mériterait qui sont des
travaux en est un qui mérite d'être
d'être lui d'être critiqués mais ça sera
même disons pour les les les auditeurs
qui sont ici les auditeurs sont
familiers avec ces questions de physique
quantique
là où les ordinateurs quantiques
fonctionne sur une superposition de
dindes ont fini de vecteurs d'état il
faudrait être capable de superposer un
nombre infini de vecteurs d'état et donc
comme on en superpole d'un nombre infini
la contribution de chacun doit être très
faible et donc il ya un moment où on est
au delà de
de deux tiers un sens physique et mêmes
mais au delà des densités d'un de
l'information qui elle serait devenue un
fini puisqu'on aurait des contributions
qui sera inférieure à 10 puissance moins
70 donc le bon donc cédé des travaux qui
au moins deux points de vue théorique
sont intéressants qu'ils intéressante
critique est intéressant de comprendre
pourquoi ces arguments ne fonctionne pas
mais pour le moment tout seul qui ont
essayé d'utiliser la mécanique quantique
pour passer la barrière de tueries ont
plutôt proposé d'aider système qui
repose sur des hypothèses assez
critiquable comme cette impossibilité de
superposer un nombre infini de qubits
dans une même dans un même état
quantique
ce qui est un une idée que les finitions
en général rejette la côte il facile à
d'ailleurs dating précisé le pr alors
c'est par exemple un double prime de
l'arrêt ces deux programmes et n'importe
quelle fonction qui ne peut pas être
programmé par la machine de turing est
du coup en fait là est ce que tu inverse
c'est un peu et qu'il se demander si je
les ai présidé la dimension de l'espèce
des libertés fini non non non c'est de
se demander la dimension des titulaires
elle est infinie quoi qu'il arrive mais
c'est de se demander si tu peux
exploiter cette affinité pour faire des
combinaisons linéaire voile puis quitte
à perdre complètement les auditeurs
autres en retard y aller complètement
il faut faire une combinaison linéaire
dont la somme des carrés des
coefficients est égal à 1
donc si tu avais une infinité tu vois il
y en a forcément une infinité d'entre
eux qui ont une contribution qui est
inférieur à 10 puissance moins soixante
dix neuf donc qui n'a pas perdu tout
sens physique voilà donc on est on est
vraiment dans de là dans la spéculation
et dans des hypothèses qui pose un
problème physique ne sont pas des
hypothèses physiquement réaliste bon
après ça empêche pas que c'est le bon
résultat et je pars avec la vente du
temps encore cg touche tout autant qui
risque de vous la voir l'implication des
tic ouais tu as artificielle parce que
quels sont les grands enjeux des tic
aujourd'hui donc je me suis intéressé à
l'éthique plus récemment que la
l'épistémologie donc tu t'es déjà
raconté une partie de ma ville comme
enjeu mais à faire de la philosophie des
sciences les questions d'éthique c'est
des questions qui n'ont pas préoccuper
pendant de très nombreuses années
et d'ailleurs je n'étais pas le seul
dans ce cas là puisque mon employeur qui
s'appelle inria existe depuis cinquante
deux ans et pendant les 40 premières
années de son existence
l'idée qu'on ait besoin d'un comité
d'éthique ne l'avait pas de traverser
l'esprit et donc on pensait qu'il était
normal que l'inserm le cnrs l'inra etc
les comités d'éthique puisque mon écran
dès qu'on touche à la santé aux vivants
c'est naturel de se poser des questions
d'éthique mais on s'en pose depuis hier
hippocrate mais en informatique on était
un peu victimes de notre proximité avec
les mathématiques ou les mathématiciens
en général n'ont pas de comité d'éthique
ou panse que
il ya bien sûr des applications des
mathématiques qui pose des problèmes
éthiques mais que les recherches elle
même en mathématiques sont suffisamment
loin des questions de deux sociétés -
des applications techniques pour
justifier l'existence d'un comité
d'éthique
je suis absolument sûr d'être d'accord
avec les mathématiciens maintenant va
enfin en tout cas quand il ya vingt ans
quand vous prenez ces questions je
disais que l'informatique c'était comme
les mathématiques avait pas de questions
d'éthique importante
et puis on s'est aperçu que malgré tout
les objets informatique était un peu
autour de nous des manières un peu
excessivement présente et donc il se
posait tout un tas de questions dont les
premières questions qu'on voit en fait
les avants avant d'aller vers plus des
questions plus profondes ccsl delà de la
collecte de données personnelles
bon on utilise toutes et tous un certain
nombre de services en ligne qui sont
gratuits et donc on se demande comment
est ce que les entreprises qui font dix
et ses services arrivent à dégager une
forme de profit et là la réponse est que
c'est l'entreprise collecte des données
sur nous vers des données des données
personnelles et les revendent revendre
ensuite ces informations alors avec les
des situations qui va être plus ou moins
embarrassante
bon il est pas très grave que si je
regarde des publicités juste ici je
regarde un site pour acheter un vélo qui
est de la publicité ciblée qui convoie à
des publicités pas qu'il ya un
algorithme qui sélectionne des
publicités pour moi est que moi on
m'envoie des publicités pour acheter des
vélos bonjour on se dit c'est pas très
grave que ça que ce soit que ce soit ça
mais il ya même des cas où ces mêmes
vertueux par exemple quand on collecte
des données médicales sur des patients
va ça permet ensuite de de mieux
connaître les maladies de concevoir de
nouveaux traitements de concevoir de
nouveaux vaccins etc
donc on se dit bon voilà on est en vrac
dans un cas vertueux mais cependant même
dans ces cas vertueux il se pose la
question de l'eau - de l'anonymisation
des données et donc des choses qu'on
veut nous faisons tous les jours envoyé
un mail utilise un moteur de recherche
et ses poses popopo pose des problèmes
éthiques donc finalement s'étaient
trompés parce que envoyé un mail c'est
pas quelque chose qu'on fait depuis dix
ans c'est quelque chose qu'on fait
depuis 30 ans ou 40 ans 40 ans
maintenant oui et c'est que oui bien sûr
qu'il sait que c'est 50 ans d'internet
la fin à la fin du mois donc c'est pas
les 50 ans du mail mais le bas il est
venu à peu près dix ans après internet
donc c'est ça fait longtemps qu'on
envoie lui mais les onze posait pas
vraiment de problèmes éthiques
au tout début et donc le
inria et le cnrs et le cea d'autres
d'autres instituts de recherche et
d'autres universités
il ya une quinzaine de quinzaine
d'années maintenant ont commencé à
réfléchir à l'idée d'avoir un comité
d'éthique et finalement je me suis
aperçu que les questions d'éthique de
l'informatique elles sont très
différentes des questions d'éthique delà
des sciences biomédicales
alors il ya une différence c'est
qu'elles sont c'est que c'est quand même
deux elles sont à la à l'éthique
biomédicale ce que la comédie est à la
tragédie
c'est à dire l'éthique biomédicale
s'intéresse principalement à trois
événements qui sont la naissance la
procréation et la mort et si on regarde
le nombre de jours de vie qui sont
concernés par ces événements et sont
assez peu nombreux malgré tout on va on
est mais en général une seule fois avec
un peu de chance on va mourir une seule
fois et puis on va pas procréer non plus
des millions de fois au cours de son
existence donc donc c'est des moments
très très rare dans l'existence dont
parlent les teams de médical mais en
revanche c'est des moments qui sont très
importants puisqu'il touche une forme de
avec un sens très générale du mot qu'on
pourrait appeler de sacrée la ville à
bord en revanche les tics de
l'informatique toucher à des problèmes
qui sont sans doute moins grave on peut
on peut penser que est moins grave de
d'accéder un mail par exemple qui ne
nous était pas destinée que de tuer
quelqu'un donc on est moins dans le
tragique mais en revanche ça ça se
produit 100 fois par jour est donc mis
bout à bout tous ces petits pros les
objectifs finissent pas en faire un
problème après l'énorme nous c'est une
première différence
ils prêtent une deuxième différence
c'est que le fait de se poser des
questions d'éthique nous mène à nous
poser de nouveaux problèmes de recherche
est un exemple de sas et l'anonymisation
dont on parlait jusqu'à
juste avant qu est ce que c est
minimisée de données on sait bien que
c'est pas juste supprimer demande
famille de tu vois si mon exemple favori
c'est le un compositeur autrichien dont
les prénoms et et wolfgang amadeus
même si je te dit pas son nom mais que
je t'ai dit qu'il aimait en 1756 qu'il
est mort en 1791 tu commences à avoir il
n'a pas pris une ride et le kid de qui
je veux parler et on se dit pour moi
c'est c'est le cas de ce compositeur
parce qu'il est très connu mais c'est le
cas d'à peu près tout le monde puisque
avec simplement ta date de naissance et
ton cancale postale on peut quasiment
identifié des tories identifiant
identifié entre 80 et 90% de la
population comme ça et c'est pas si
surprenant parce que quand tu multiplies
le nombre de dates de naissance possible
par le nombre de codes postaux possible
pour des enclos - quatre-vingt dix ans
et à peu près trente mille et le nombre
de codes postaux c'est 100 milles
donc quand on multiplie 30000 par 100
milles ça fait 3 milliards et donc sur
ces 3 milliards de combinaisons
en france par exemple y en a que 66
millions qui sont utilisées donc la
probabilité qu'ils ont des deux qui sont
exactement est très faible et donc la
plupart des gens sont frustrés
identifiables par un truc complètement
anodin mais juste à date de naissance en
le mettant dans ton prénom pour l'uni
naissance etc
il réussit en code postal et la date de
naissance et on sait à peu près quitter
tout de suite donc voilà qu'est ce que
ça veut dire anonymisées dans ce cas là
et donc ça fait que inria par exemple il
ya trois ou quatre équipes qui se pose
juste cette question là qu'est ce que ça
veut dire à minimiser c'est un problème
de recherche qui est nouveau on pourrait
dire autant au niveau électronique le
tout un tas de 2,2 situation éthique
dont on sait pas très bien
non c'est quelque chose que de gens
compétents se souviennent mais admission
post bac
elle posera problème éthique extrêmement
intéressant qui est ce que le tirage au
sort est juste ou injuste et ça c'est
une question qui est discutée depuis
l'antiquité et on est plutôt tendance
dans l'antiquité avancé que le tirage au
sort était juste et on s'est aperçu que
maintenant c'était ce qui était
considéré comme étant ce qui était le
plus juste et ouais donc ça ça posait
des questions de recherche sur cela un
lien entre aléas et justice qui est qui
était tout à fait qu'ils sont tout à
fait tout à fait nouvelle les gens
considèrent sadriste en tout cas les
lycéens qui étaient envoyés dans une
filière x ou y en fonction un tirage au
sort trouvé que c'était plus injuste que
que si on les avait envoyés dans cette
même section où cette même filière c'est
ce même programme d'études en fonction
de leurs mérites de leurs notes au bac
par exemple le fait que ça soit un
processus aléatoire alors qu'il est le
processus aléatoires donc tu n'as pas
ajouté l'est des îles et en espérance
parfaitement parfaitement équitable mais
une fois que les dés sont tombés il ya
rien de plus inéquitable que l'envoyer
en étudiante à deux étudiants qui
voulaient fermer de signes mâcon avons
en médecine l'autre on envoie faire
quelque chose de complètement différent
forcément celui qui fait autre chose il
considère ça injuste
on vient pas demander si en espérance
c'était juste d'être ici a posteriori
c'est s était juste et ça c'est quelque
chose de une transformation dans l'idée
de hasard qui est qui
ok nouvelle mais ta question portait sur
les questions d'intelligence
artificielle c'est à dire aujourd'hui ce
mot a pris le sens assez précis qui le
l'apprentissage automatique et ici il ya
de nouvelles questions qui apparaissent
qui sont qui sont tout à fait tout à
fait intéressante est tout à fait
différente des questions qui étaient
apparues dans le cas dans le disons des
réseaux du web
du partage d'informations et une des
unes des questions qui ce se qui se pose
c'est est ce qu'il est possible de
prendre une décision sur une base pour
voir statistiques et ça c'est que c'est
une question qui qui qui ont finalement
relativement relativement nouvelle il ya
bien sûr des vieilles questions éthiques
alors je vais essayer le politiquement
correct mais disons si tu as deux
groupes de personnes demandant une
population et que les dons qu'ils ont la
peau bleue ils ont la peau verte et ceux
qui ont la peau verte sont
statistiquement 10 % + 2 fois
délinquants que c'est qu'on la peau
bleue et jeu qu'on peut mettre en prison
quelqu'un parce qu'il avait ouverte
alors date d'un point de vue qu'on
appelle conséquentialiste aussi bah oui
si on met les il faut les mettre en
prison puis s'ils sont plus souvent
délinquants que les bleus dont pour la
la la la la la paix ou la tranquillité
des bleus il faut mettre les verts en
prison mais il yad'autres d'autres
considérations éthiques qui s'appuie
moins sur l'idée de conséquences mais
plus sur l'idée de vertu les valeurs
quelles sont les valeurs qu'on défend
l'idée de mettre quelqu'un en prison
non pas parce qu'il a commis un crime
mais parce que des gens qui lui
ressemble que bien un crime est une idée
qui vous est assez qui nous rebute et
donc avec l'apprentissage statistiques
on arrive non pas à mettre des gens en
prison parce que ils ressemblent à des
gens qui sont des délinquants mais on
arrive par exemple a accordé en prêt à
quelqu'un dans une banque
parce qu'il ressemble à quelqu'un qui
pense qu'il a une tête
il a un profil à rembourser son prêt et
a refusé un prêt à d'autres personnes
parce que ayant un profil à ne pas
refuser anota à ne pas rembourser le
prêt donc tant qu'on a l'air
d'algorithmes simple qui disait par
exemple il faut que les mensualités du
prêt soit inférieure à un tiers de vos
revenus
on était capable d'expliquer aux gens
pourquoi on leur donnait un prêt ou non
on leur accordait un prêt ou non
mais à partir du moment où c'est plus
qu'à et où on prend un un algorithme qui
mélange des milliers de critères selon
dd que des combinaisons linéaire dont
les coefficients sont eux mêmes trouver
par optimisation de manière à les
expliquer au mieux ce qu'on a fait dans
d'autres cas eh bien on s'aperçoit qu'on
prend une décision sans du tout capable
de l'expliquer et tout ce qu'on peut
dire à un client si on vous a refusé le
prêt parce que va vous ressembler à des
gens vous ressemblez à trop de gens qui
vont pas rembourser leurs prêts par le
par le passé et donc ça c'est une vraie
une vraie question qui est là là là au
conflit entre ray qui craint conflit
entre cette vision purement
conséquentialiste de l'éthique c'est à
dire il faut essayer de prendre des
décisions de manière à ce que les
conséquences soient le mieux possible
pour le plus grand nombre et et de
l'autre côté une éthique qui est plus
une éthique de vertus de valeurs où on
dit bah non si on refuse un prêt avec
quelqu'un il faut lui expliquer pourquoi
lui on leur refuse le prêt est pas
pourquoi il a l'air d'être dans une dans
une catégorie de gens qui n'ont pas les
têtes à rembourser à rembourser leur
prêt donc c'est des questions qui sont à
la fois pas tout à fait de nouvelles en
éthique on peut remonter mon collègue
alexei grinbaum défend cette thèse que
moi je joue un peu excessivement fin en
tout cas elle a le mérite d'être
intéressante à discuter que toutes les
questions est il qu'on se pose
aujourd'hui on s'était déjà posée sous
une autre forme
par le passé et il suffit de le
transposer de trouver le problème qu'il
appelle homologues mais bon moi je suis
un peu réservé sur cette tête est déjà
bien en discuter avec lui mais je suis
pas sûr d'être complètement d'accord
avec lui il ya aussi des nouvelles des
nouvelles questions des nouvelles
considérations éthiques qui apparaît
c'est qu'ils sont
voilà qui mérite qui mérite qu'on s'y
intéresse et qui mérite qu'on y
réfléchisse
je gère un autre exemple comme celle de
ce genre c'est sur ma chaîne en fait
masculine et j'ai l'impression qu'il
parle c'est le cas de tout ce qui me
semble assez probable c'est que les
recommandations en fait toi est ce genre
de petits biaou la personne sylvain vu
que l'algorithme a peut-être vu que les
hommes regardent un peu plus oui plume
transfert de vidéos dès que quelqu'un
est un homme ne va tout de suite se
ruiner beaucoup plus et plus en plus à
un cercle et donc est ce que tu peux
faire contre ça j'essaie de faire c'est
ça c'est ça la vraie question éthique en
éthique n'est pas juste de dire c'est
bien c'est mal où il faut et c'est aussi
de comprendre quelque élection peut on
peut avoir est donc alors diverses
possibilités mais je ne conseille pas
forcément la première c'est quitter
youtube et de créer tout et même une
plateforme où il n'y a pas du tout
recommandations alors ça ça pose deux
problèmes le premier c'est que comme la
plupart des gens sont sur youtube
personnel et sur sa plate forme mais
surtout s'il n'y a pas du tout de
recommandation ça deviendra assez
compliqué de retrouver tes vidéos
arrivent sur tes vidéos parce qu'elles
sont recommandés donc ensuite on peut se
poser la question de savoir comment
faire pour éviter que dans les
recommandations il ya un biais de genre
et donc on pourrait décider que à chaque
fois qu'une vidéo est recommandé un
homme parce que pour tout un tas de
raisons
eh bien il faut que l'algorithme trouve
une femme avec qui recommande et et
vidéos de manière à les recommander à
autant d'hommes que de femmes
même si les raisons indépendantes du
genre pour lesquelles on la recommande
ait été plus forte dans un cas comme
dans l'autre il c'est pas grave on
rajoute un billet une espèce de bié
positive au sens de la discrimination
positive après ce que ça va amener plus
de femmes à regarder des vidéos s'avance
arriérés
mais le cse c'est ce genre de question
qui se pose est qu'ils ont c'est un
autre point c'est que c'est vraiment des
questions qu'il faut aller jusqu'au bout
et les maîtres et les maîtres et les
mettre en pratique et une autre question
qui se pose ici c'est ciron ont défini
des règles éthiques des règles morales
donc on n'est plus dans une éthique
normative une éthique où la notion
centrale des nessel bêta de fait de
conséquence ni celle de de valeur mais
celle de normes celle de celle de règles
est ce qu'on peut
est ce qu'on doit avoir des règles qui
sont implémentées dans un algorithme et
qui du coup sont nécessairement
impliquer et l'ours est un à un une idée
qui a été amené par un autre
informaticien qui s'appelle lui versini
qui propose l'idée que les le code de la
route par exemple il faut aller mieux
considérés comme des lois physiques donc
on te dit que il est interdit de
franchir une ligne blanche
mais c'est pas juste qu'il est interdit
en france que ce soit impossible et donc
du coup ci c'est un algorithme qui
conduit la voiture
il ne faut pas franchir la ligne blanche
à aucun prix et donc par exemple s'il a
la vitesse est limitée à 80 km heure tu
peux rouler à 79 kilomètres heure mais à
80 si tu veux mais pas à 81 et l'ours il
ya un incendie qui se propage 80,1
kilomètres heure mais que ce soit si
tout roule à 80 km/heure
il va finir par te rattraper alors que
si tu dépassait de deux kilomètres heure
la vitesse limite tu vois la 82e qui
pourraient échapper l'incendié mais
c'est pas grave l'important c'est de
respecter que la règle soit respectée
puis tant pis si tu dubrulle dans
l'instant dû parce que si on commence à
être autorisé à rouler 80 2 pourquoi pas
90 pourquoi pas 140 et puis pourquoi pas
tous les joueurs donc ce qu'il faut
tenir compte de la sen du coup non et
alors ça c'est une question qui est à la
fois ça sera un problème moral que
plutôt que d'avoir des règles d'un côté
et puis nos comportements de l'autre et
qui est en gros rien à voir entre les
deux ce serait beaucoup dire mais disons
que on souhaite toujours dans la
transgression ma 2e manon essayons grâce
à une implémentation dans des véhicules
autonomes pareillement du code de la
route et c'est andré que les voitures
respecte tout le temps le code de la
route et on s'aperçoit que no no no no
éthiques ont été construites pour pour
elles ont été elles ont été construites
elle reflète nos valeurs mais elles sont
en gros impossible à appliquer à la
lettre
c'est à dire il est laid que celui qui
n'a jamais dépassé une vitesse limite me
jette la première pierre
voilà ils ont il ya toujours des moments
où on est sur le point transgresser la
règle on la transgressent etc
et il ya même tout un processus de
rédemption de reconnaissance de la faute
de correction de la faute de rédemption
etc et eu lieu dit pas tout ça c'est
plus nécessaire il suffit que les règles
soient respectées
mais du coup ça ça nous amène à nous
dire si maintenant on fait des règles
mais pas pour rigoler on fait des règles
vraiment qu'ils arrêtent pour qu'elle
soit respectée
à ce moment là il faut que les règles
soient beaucoup plus supportables
beaucoup plus vivable que les règles les
lois et les normes que l'on à
aujourd'hui qui dont on s'aperçoit qu'on
n'arrive pas vraiment à les respecter à
dos reis le code de la route ou les
limitations de vitesse
et donc c'est intéressant parce que ça
veut dire qu'il faut vraiment penser
aujourd'hui les normes éthiques comme
comme devant prendre comme devant être
possiblement mise en oeuvre et il faut
pas s'imposer à soi même des règles
éthiques qui se rate qui seraient trop
strict à tel point qu'on puisse pas les
complices pas les respecter
alors j'ai appris récemment que c'était
déjà le cas par exemple je croyais vrai
que les le code de la route nous donner
des limitations de vitesse et que les
ambulances ou les voitures de pompiers
ou les voitures de police ne respectait
pas à ces limitations de vitesse mais
que mais que c'était juste une
transgression du code de la route qui
était autorisée en fait non c'est
inscrit dans le code de la route ne
siègerait pas mon code otan russie leurs
pays apparemment il était inscrit j'ai
dû savoir à jour il est inscrit dans le
code de la route qui a un certain nombre
de véhicules qui ont le droit de
dépasser des vitesses ligne mais dans
une certaine mesure dans certaines
conditions cet arrêté est pas tout le
temps et pas n'importe quel prix et
c'est donc il faudrait par exemple qu'il
y ait des règles de programmes à
finition on imagine un véhicule autonome
il faudrait qu'on puisse dire aux
véhicules autonomes attention je ne suis
pas une ambulance mais aujourd'hui je
transportais un blessé donc il faut
appliquer des règles un peu différente
un peu plus relâché par rapport à aux
règles aux règles habituelles de là et
si tu dis voilà je vais être en retard
au cinéma il faudra dépasser les
vitesses limites on te disent mais non
ça c'est pas un calque est prévu dans le
cas des dents dans le code de la route
donc la nature même des règles si on
suppose qu'elles doivent être vraiment
sans rigoler appliquée elle est
différente et ça aussi c'est une
transformation de de l'éthique qui moi
j'ai tendance à appeler un progrès moral
c'est à dire je considère que avoir des
règles extrêmement strictes
et puis finalement mener une vie qui n'a
rien à voir avec les règles strictes
qu'on prétend défendre
c'est une situation qui est immoral et
que avoir des règles certes plus souple
puisque après tout ne sommes que des
êtres humains donc il faut pas nous
entre autres aux gens demander quand
même mais que ça soit des rails qui
puisse être appliquée est un progrès
moral voilà mais bon c'est des questions
qui sont bien sûr très débattue je suis
pas sûr que tout le monde d'accord avec
ça mais ça rend est ce qu'on se disait
tout à l'heure sur le la différence
entre le raisonnement est calculé en
particulier si une intelligence
artificielle doit appliquer des règles
il faut que ce soit des allures et
pourquoi donc ça c'est clair du coup
pensé à l'année les tickets de manière
de manière algorithmique et alors cela
dit les tic ça souvent en éthique ya pas
que des raisonnements il ya des
raisonnements et des actions
c'est-à-dire faire une éthique il soit
purement une éthique spéculative
ça n'a aucun intérêt ce qui est
intéressant dans l'éthique c'est qu'à la
fin ça débouche sur des actions
sinon si c'est juste pour dire ça
seniors ça s'est mal passé pas très
intéressant ce qui est intéressant c'est
de savoir en quoi ça ça peut transformer
notre action ouais c'est intéressant si
parce que l'on peut avoir du coût des
contraintes aussi algorithmique
je pense notamment à des articles qui
essaie de réfléchir à quelles étaient
les décisions que va prendre une voiture
autonome mais une contrainte
algorithmique assénant qui est que vers
dans les situations de de tig est une
contrainte highway africa ces normes
c'est que quelqu'un doit se faire en
quelques secondes oui c'est aussi la
rage ou est adéquat des filles oui oui
tout à fait mais c'est un des exemples
où on considère tout à fait normal de de
transnet et des règles et donc est celui
où une voiture doit prendre une décision
à une décision b donc après on peut
remplacer a et b parce qu'on veut
écraser cinq enfants ne viennent
un motard avec un casque à moto sans
casque etc auxquels et des de nombreux
cas mais surtout ce qui est intéressant
c'est que si jamais ce type de situation
se produit c'est comme relativement rare
mais si jamais ça se produit avec un
conducteur humain eh bien on va on sait
que conducteur humain va pas avoir le
temps de se souvenir ce que quand tu
disais est ce que les abs combiné son
côté disait de regarder le ca du canada
près du conséquentialiste mais aussi du
point de vue des tic des vertus bons
rails et un dixième de seconde comme tu
le dis puis fait n'importe quoi elle
puis après il y brille j'ai pas réfléchi
j'ai pris le temps de réfléchir j'ai
fait ce que j'ai fait je ne sais pas
l'expliquer en revanche si on est dans
le cas de programmer un véhicule
autonome en décidant de mettre un choix
ou un autre
à ce moment là on va prendre la décision
dix ans avant que le coin ne se produise
et donc là la règle qu'on va décider
elle sera vraiment mise en oeuvre le
jour où l'heure où les problèmes se
produire parce qu'elle aura été
programmés bon le dans le code de la
delà du véhicule autonome et donc là on
n'est pas juste en train de réfléchir à
un problème extrait on est vraiment en
train de réfléchir un problème qui va
changer le comportement le comportement
de la voiture et c'est en cela qu'on
s'aperçoit que les règles ne sont plus
uniquement une référence un peu l'idéal
qu'on peut discuter tout en sachant que
de toute façon les transgresse parce
qu'on a un dixième de seconde pour
prendre une décision
mais elles vont vraiment être appliqué
et donc à ce moment là là là là la
question de
de d'avoir les règles qui sont qui font
qu'on a envie de monter dans la voiture
quand même donc des règles qui sont
vraiment compatible avec ce qu'on
souhaite et pas uniquement qui sont
compactés avec des beaux principes on se
berce le respectais de devient cruciale
et donc c'est là je pense qu'on est
vraiment au coeur de la de la question
de l'éthique de l'informatique et de la
tendance artificiel aujourd'hui
enfin voilà l'exemple que je prends
toujours c'est la gouaille de
recommandations de youtube ouais en
particulier oui puissiez me retourne à
sion et râlent mais particulier youtube
qui commande aujourd'hui tous les jours
des milliers de vidéos à des millions à
des millions d'utilisateurs et à tracer
recommandations il ya des vrais dylan et
font des questions et des crises on est
très très important et il allait séparer
cette édition qui doivent être faites en
quelques migrants au moyen de secondes
lorsque le patient et je pense que c'est
vraiment un des enjeux et oui tout à
fait authentique et problème de non mais
c'est vrai tu as tu as raison ça nous
ramène un peu trop misé juste avant
c'est que le on a tendance à incarner
ces dilemmes éthiques avec des des
questions d'éthique classique de vie et
de mort le véhicule autonome qui va
écraser x ou y etc
mais peut-être que les questions
éthiques plus quotidienne comme les
questions de recommandation de deux
vidéos sont plus importantes et
peut-être qu'on le voit pas parce que
effectivement sur chaque recommandation
de vidéos
il n'y a pas un enjeu éthique énorme
mais finalement sur des milliards de
recommandations qui sont faites à des
milliards d'utilisateurs
il fit ça finit par statistiquement
avoir avoir loué influence c'est sur ce
que les gens pensent sur la manière dont
les gens agissent in history statistics
sort sur youtube c'est aujourd'hui le
plus de vues sur youtube que de
recherche sur google
d'accord et 70% des vu son résultat de
recommandations d agri dating
oui donc il ya une main de 70% de 1
milliard de ça fait beaucoup de gens il
ya un an le gardeur de vues par jour
d'accord et donc on s'aperçoit que les
valeurs éthiques et les règles éthiques
les normes éthiques qui sont dans cette
belle voix de recommandations et en
influence elle sur ce que les gens
pensent ce que les gens font même gros
enjeu ce que je pense qu'il ya deux ans
puis de recherche dans ce domaine
oui oui oui c'est alors c'est un domaine
qui est qui est compliqué à faire
émerger puisque c'était une des
difficultés qu'on avait au début dans ce
comité d'éthique avait été créé par une
ria le cnrs qui s'appelle qui s'appelle
la serna et qui est en train d'évoluer
vers autre chose c'était que c'était
assez compliqué de se comprendre donc au
départ il y avait ce qui était un bon
choix il y avait des informaticiens des
philosophes des juristes des des
sociologues géographes enfin disons d
mais disons pour faire simple il y avait
d'un côté et l'informaticien de l'autre
côté les sciences humaines qui décorent
leur galaxie de petites différences
entre la géographie l'anah sociaux etc
et c'était c'était compliqué de changer
parce que les les mots avec des sifflets
sont différents parce que les questions
qui étaient posées étaient différentes
les enjeux étaient différentes et
c'était assez intéressant parce que
pendant les premières réunions c'est que
des réunions assez pénible et pas très
intéressante où les gens d et moi en
tant que juriste je pense que moi en
tant qu'informaticien je vous je vous ai
sûr que c'est grave
c'était un peu et puis tout d'un coup
c'était beaucoup lié à la personnalité
back gauche et qui présidait ce comité
et qui est max avait fait beaucoup pour
que c'est tout le monde écoute tout le
monde tout le monde répondra tout le
monde peut vous prendre en compte le
point de vue de tout le monde etc
après il y avait vraiment une volonté de
créer quelque chose ensemble et donc il
ya eu un moment ça a complètement
disparu et tout d'un coup on avait créé
un langage commun et on avait on se
comprenait on écoutait les autres chacun
reconnaissait volontiers que son domaine
de compétences etc
donc c'était donc tout la crise et créer
quelque chose et c'est quelque chose qui
est difficile à reproduire 10 ans et
mais c'est nécessaire de le faire à une
grande échelle
donc c'est compliqué d'interagir avec
des gens d'autres communautés de
recherche et surtout les communes et de
recherche qui sont très éloignées des
nôtres comme comme les juristes ils ont
là un cours d'informatique ça ressemble
un peu à un cours de physique à 120
cours de chimie ça ressemble un peu à un
cours de maths mais en cours de droit
c'est ça a rien à voir avec ça c'est
vraiment c'est vraiment une autre
planète et donc ce dialogue il est
beaucoup plus difficile à établir mais
cela dit ça vaut le coup parce que quand
on arrive à l'établir c'est vraiment
quelque chose de très neutre et de très
fructueux donc faire émerger de nouveaux
de nouvelles équipes de recherche sur
ces sujets c'est moi c'est vraiment
quelque chose qui me semble qui me
semble important mais en sachant qu' il
ya toujours un risque qui est il faut
vraiment tout faire pour que se produise
pas mais c'est un risque réel que il ya
d'un côté les informaticiens qui
travaillent dans leur coin sont des
éléments une indemnisation de l'autre
côté les juristes qui écrivent des
articles pour d'autres juristes et que
le
la la la symbiose ne se produise pas
mais quand elle se produit c'est
vraiment génial donc c'est vraiment une
expérience qu'il faut qu'il faut tenter
en sachant que c'est déjà très difficile
de faire ce que les gens se parlent mais
quand ils se parlent après je pense que
tout le tout va après ça avance très
vite j'ai essayé terre d'une
coordination de combien de personnes on
est une vingtaine donc donc c'est
beaucoup
déjà parlé à 20 c'est pas simple bon
après on les vins il ya des groupes plus
petits etc
mais c'est mais même dans les roues plus
petits mais ils tous le racing diversité
des spécialités des points de vue etc
et voilà donc il faut apprendre à
s'écouter il faut apprendre à comprend
par les langages de l'autre et il faut
apprendre à penser que l'autruche que
dit l'autre est sans doute plus
intéressant que je comprends ce soit
donc des chercheurs c'est très compliqué
d'arriver à s'intégrer cette idée mais
mais ça ça vaut vraiment la peine à
temps pour développer notre jeu c'est
pas ça a pris bon c'est aussi c'était
pas des réunions qui était très
fréquente donc on était une réunion par
mois et ça a pris 3 4 mois ils ont trois
quatre réunions donc si on pense que ces
trois quilles trois quatre fois deux
heures c'est pas trés pas très long mais
bon c'était c'était malgré tout faire
d'effort qu'il fallait faire et que je
pense tout le monde a fait de bonne
volonté dans le groupe et c'était ça a
porté ses fruits
ok c'est quoi les prochaines étapes
alors c'est le second ce comité a été
créé pour être un comité d'éthique de la
recherche
donc en théorie ça sa fonction ces
impertinents sa légitimité c'est
uniquement de 2
recommandé aux chercheurs certaines
certaines questions que les chercheurs
devraient se poser mais bien entendu on
voit bien que les questions qu'on a
discuté des pages de loin les questions
d'éthique de la recherche bien ok bien
entendu des questions d'éthique qui ce
qui se trouve le chercheur comme par
exemple est ce qu'ils on peut utiliser
telle ou telle méthode d'apprentissage
dans telle ou telle application donc
c'est lalalalala utiliser des
algorithmes d'apprentissage pour rendre
la justice piloter des avions faire des
jeux vidéo etc sont des questions tout à
fait différente
donc il faut vraiment avoir des points
de vue assez précis et en particulier
sur les questions de recherche mais bon
comme on le voit c'est des questions qui
dépassent de beaucoup les délégations de
recherche et donc le l'inspiration
aujourd'hui c'est d'eux que ces
réflexions éthiques dépassent le cadre
strict de l'éthique de la recherche pour
aller au delà dans une éthique de
l'informatique une éthique de de
l'apprentissage machine une éthique de
la communication qui aille au delà des
questions d'éthique de la recherche du
coup il ya aussi des projets de
recherche alors que c'est c'est dommage
mais c'est quelque chose qui commence à
émerger
mais c'est beaucoup d plutôt d'aider
coopération bilatérale c'est à dire on
n'a pas de des kits de recherche ni à la
fac de droit ni à une riani dans les
facs de 2,2 sociaux d'anthropologie et
c'est qui qui sont dédiés à ces
questions d'éthique de l'informatique il
y en a quelques-unes par exemple est
belle sont très en avance m dont
plusieurs mai mais pour le moment mais
on est encore dans une étape où par
exemple des gens écrire des papiers 2
mais chacun restant dans son vin son
équipe est dans son laboratoire donc on
n'est plus dans des domaines de la
recherche coopérative que dans l'idée de
créer vraiment une
une équipe nouvelle donc mais je pense
que ça soit ils ont c'est l'étape
suivante du processus de construction
parce que c'est il ya d'autres questions
qui y est que pendant longtemps on a vu
les tic un peu comme une limitation de
en particulier de la recherche
donc tu dis que si tu pouvais couper les
gens en morceaux car les expériences
sans aucune contrainte faire de la
recherche
mieux en fait on s'aperçoit que c'est le
contraire qui est vrai c'est à dire que
loin d'être un frein à l'innovation
l'éthique est devenu aujourd'hui une
condition nécessaire de l'innovation
c'est à dire si on fait un moteur de
recherche qui diffuse des informations
confidentielles personnelles sur des
gens sans anonymisées sans les prévenir
et cetera eh bien ces produits ne vont
pas être utilisés et donc que le
l'éthique mais plus un frein à
développer de nouvelles choses mais
c'est devenu nécessaire si on veut que
les gens utilisent ses services ses
produits et d'avoir une réflexion
éthique de manière à ce que on répondre
réelle attente des gens parce que pour
les gens qui font des services de
produits leur but est donc sa salle fait
sacrer la nécessité de véritables
réflexions éthiques
à tous les niveaux donc au niveau de la
recherche et au niveau industriel au
niveau technique au niveau de la société
au niveau de l'état par exemple que
l'informatisation de l'état qu'un truc
important où sont les où sont les
limites éthiques par exemple est-ce que
le lait ni des cons on tique a
finalement été très critiqué l'idée qu'à
mais l'administration fiscale d'utiliser
les pages facebook
des contribuables pour essayer de voir
s'il n'allait pas trouver des
informations qui est l'histoire avec
leur déclaration de revenus là on est de
quel côté est ce que c'est bien chaussé
mal or c'est bien de les plus d'impôts
c'est bien de lutter contre les
contrôles les fraudeurs est ce que c'est
bien d'observer toute la population est
ce que on utilise des informations qui
ont été mis sur facebook par les jambes
dans une certaine fidélité avec une
certaines destinations puis finalement
les utilisent pour une destination tout
cas soit une finalité tout à fait
différente
voilà donc sa sacrée plein de problèmes
éthiques donc on s'aperçoit que l'état
aussi doit doit réfléchir à ces
questions
donc ya pas que les entreprises et les
chercheurs il ya vraiment il faut aussi
par exemple la l'administration qui
découvrit réfléchir donc oui je vois pas
comment on pourrait éviter qu'il y ait
une explosion de deux jeux nombre de
gens du nombre de groupes qui
réfléchissent à ces questions après
c'est des questions qui croissent très
très doucement très voilà c'est s'il
suffit pas de décréter comme on doit se
mettre à faire de l'éthique et que tout
le monde le fasse par exemple on aurait
inclus aujourd'hui de plus en plus des
ces considérations éthiques dans la
formation des chercheurs mais je pense
qu'à terme pour les inclure dans la
formation des étudiants voire des
lycéens et c'est donc ce qui me ramène
une à nouveau une édition précédente
mais le voilà donc si tous les profs de
lycée somme est à enseigner l'éthique
oui forcément ça fera plus de monde
concerné par ces questions très cool
passé d'autres choses à rajouter non
écoute la tumeur et puis encore de
démarcation du hockey français
quel message qu'est que tu aideras que
j'en retiens de cette discussion où
l'alors attend traditionnellement
tellement riche alors voilà je voudrais
passer un message aux lycéennes en leur
disant fait de l'informatique donc non
seulement je vais passer un message à
toutes les femmes pour leur dire de
regarder des vidéos davantage
mais les chiffres qu'on a sur le choix
de la spécialité informatique en
premières sont très inquiétants en
termes de genre donc on est déjà
universitaires des départements les plus
genre et après je crois infirmières et
d'être moderne mais mais bon c'est
vraiment quelque chose de triste
d'autant plus que l'informatique qui a
été créée par disons les deux premiers
d'informaticiens de l'histoire on peut
considérer que c'est un charles babbage
delbreil c'est donc à cette époque il y
avait deux personnes dans la communauté
et la communauté était totalement
paritaire s'accordent pour chanteurs et
50% de femmes et c'est très bien qu'on
revienne à 7 à cet état voilà donc et
c'est pas je pense que le bon endroit au
bon endroit où le bug se produit c'est
au lycée
enfin l'endroit pardon l'endroit où se
produit au lycée et la phrase que je
voulais dire c'était le bon endroit pour
corriger le bug c'est le lycée parce que
à l'université si on a dans un amphi
quatre-vingt dix hommes et dix femmes on
peut
donner des points supplémentaires aux
femmes ou ou pas aimé ça va pas changer
fondamentalement le fait qu'il ya déjà
plus de femmes dans les amphis alors que
au lycée il ya beaucoup de femmes et
s'il y en avait davantage qui
choisissait de faire de l'informatique
mais je crois que la communauté serait
plus équilibrée et les objets
informatique qu'on produit serait
produit par les gens qui ont une plus
grande diversité et donc qui aurait on
aurait des objets un peu plus riches
quoi je dis souvent aux lycéennes
essayez d'imaginer ce que sera la
littérature soit bien tyjnia où le sang
guerres traunstein sont intéressés à rod
ça s'est moins bien je pense pas que ces
trois hôtels aura une écriture de femme
sur je pense que certaines rues y ait
d'autres noms face à certaines
revendiquent est d'avoir une écriture de
femme d'autres non mais c'est je pense
que les femmes écrivent différemment ou
face des objets informatiques différents
des hommes mais je pense que c'est bien
qu'il ya des hommes et des femmes qui
fait qu'ils écrivent et des hommes et
des femmes qui fait ce qu'il fait ces
objets voilà donc ça sera bon message
fait de l'informatique tout allait super
et à ce que tu vas finir peut-être avec
une augmentation de 2 livres de
personnes que ce courrier à auditionner
alors j'ai cité plein de gens en fait
dans le dock une personne une personne
que je pense qu'il devrait auditionner
cu bercy 10 pensent ils
il entra va tout à fait dans le dans le
cadre de ton podcast
après tout les gens que j'ai cités
pas de boire il dit et c'est grinbaum
laurence devillers enfin ce sont des
gens super qui serait intéressant de que
tu es auditionne mais super bon bah
merci à toi